some cities may run dry that's a quote
diesel is getting dangerously low in
this country and I I don't think I think
I think it'd be a long shot that we
actually run out of diesel in this
country but what it does mean when we're
facing a major shortage and some cities
run dry it means they're going to
prioritize where the diesel goes and who
gets it this means it's going to become
increasingly expensive when that when
that happens everything else becomes
more and more expensive including
regular old gasoline now I think this
story is particularly important because
we are one week away from election day
and this news could not possibly be
worse for Democrats so we'll see I
suppose we do have other news that guy
who attacked Paul Pelosi he's pleading
not guilty another story some
state-level democrat was mercilessly
beaten in his backyard and now we've got
DHS issuing a warning about escalating
violence that and of course Elon Musk
has announced at least the plan so far
eight dollars for the premium Twitter
blue package which includes some kind of
verification but he said
there's going to be a tag on on public
figure profiles so you will know who is
a journalist or a public figure or
whatever outside of the verification
badge so you can verify yourself but if
you're noteworthy I suppose you'll get
tagged or something
I just say take away the the symbol of
elitism who cares let these people cry
about it Elon he is learning the hard
way that Communists don't want to pay
for things because they're all
complaining saying I don't want to pay
for a service okay fine Elon tell him
you're taxing them and then they'll be
like oh well okay that's fine all right
so we'll talk about that plus a bunch of
other stories crazy story Chris
pavlovsky of of uh Rumble CEO is saying
that France is trying to get them to
take down RT and they're refusing so the
censorship is is here of course we'll
talk about this before we get started my
friends head over to timcast.com become
a member to support our work directly
click that join us button and you'll get
access to the exclusive members only
uncensored shows every night at about 11
pm there was a glitch which resulted in
yesterday's not going up but we got it
up in the morning so it is there if you
want to watch last night's it is
available and I apologize for that but
we will have tonight's up for you on
time that you have my word or I will sit
here all night to make sure that happens
don't forget to smash that like button
subscribe to this channel share the
share with your friends joining us today
to talk about this and so much more is
five times August hi who are you well uh
independent singer-songwriter from
Dallas Texas I've been writing recording
music since uh 2001 under the name five
times August had a lot of music on TV
commercials movies
um tour the country played a lot of
colleges
uh took some time off to raise a family
started a uh
started a kids music project called The
Juice Box jukebox and 2018 did that up
until 2020 and then got fed up with the
world and started releasing some protest
music in early 2021 and I have a new
album out called Silent War today and
you have absolutely incredible fantastic
memes and meme videos that I have to
commend you on my website is
thebestpoliticalshorts.com and I got 99
problems but inflation made them 109 199
problems plus tax is the message that I
have for you for here today and if you
guys like the message and want to
support me and my efforts here you can
on the best politicalshirts.com because
you do I'm here thank you again so much
for having me I just realized whenever
we start the show I'll introduce the
guest Luke Ian and Sarah I never say my
own name
It's like because you didn't you didn't
introduce yourself and then I was like
Luke you gotta say you're Luke Krakowski
if we are change and then do it but you
know normally normally I'll say like
Lucas here the T-shirt vendor it's
awkward it's same in movies and TV when
you're writing scripts you got to make
sure that the characters say each
other's names once at the very beginning
so that the audience doesn't wander yeah
I'm Ian crosson by the way oh well it's
nice to meet you you too Brad I'm Rick
manfrey welcome to the Rickman show
hello Rick can we make up our own names
sure yeah what's your oh what's his name
cowboy no no no no no no no no no no no
uh uh Winston uh uh juice Piedmont
oligma Johnson
all right legma thanks for hanging out
what's happening over there brother oh
yeah I'm serge.com trying to get this
all right here nice happy guys yeah
thanks man people were commending it the
other day I love it it's a mighty fine
Tuesday my friends
that's right it's got a little what's
what does the puff ball do
uh I have no idea I actually have no
idea it's always been on hats you know
just
there you go who knows it's just always
been there it's just the way we do it at
some point somebody was like there's got
to be a puff ball on top I wonder if
it's a mimic being a large animal for
like back in the day they would put like
a horse's hair on the top so that when
you come into contact with a bear and
you have to get a big to scare it oh
that makes it look the puff ball scares
bears away that explains it I don't see
any bears here do you well there you go
nailed it all right how about we talk
about news yeah all right everybody
here's the here's the story and it's
it's actually really simple
quote some cities may run dry for a few
days a few days I wonder what that means
for you how do you feel about not having
gas for your truck for a few days that
sounds fun diesel supplier warns
businesses on the east coast to prepare
for diesel shortage after Russia cut off
Imports the other day on the show people
were super chatting that the supply was
down to like 20 or 19 days it's still
down it's it's not improving they are
resupplying but not as fast as we are
consuming so it is getting a little bit
worrisome that our diesel supplies are
the lowest point since like 2008. have
you guys I just want to point this out
too diesel supplies are at the lowest
since 2008 like uh more housing prices
mortgage rates interest rates like all
of these things are starting to we keep
hearing like inflation is worse since
two as bad as it's been since 2008 you
know they keep they keep saying that you
guys remember what happened then right
in 2008 yeah yeah we almost completely
toppled the economy almost that we uh we
taxed everyone I don't know 10 I think
over the course of 20 years they're
going to pay out 20 trillion or
something to pay off those Banks from
2008 I don't know the exact numbers they
say businesses which rely on the fuel
have been told to take steps to plan for
the potential lack of Supply which is
mostly caused by Russia cutting off
Imports this means that businesses are
not receiving the high number of
petroleum products they were before the
invasion of Ukraine the diesel shortage
is also caused by high distillate demand
refinery maintenance and lower Refinery
capacity
you know it's it's a scary story but
let's be real Democrats all have Teslas
so this isn't going to bother them at
all right I mean Pete booted judge it
was him right he told everyone to buy
Tesla well there you go problem solved
Democrats don't have to worry about it
midterm yeah AOC has one she's probably
really happy now and what was that
congresswoman that said that when gas
prices were high she was driving by her
with her Tesla and and celebrating that
she didn't need to pay like the other
peasants what was her name I forgot oh
yeah
I'll look it up I don't know but come on
look come on are you so so so they're
saying because of the diesel shortages
you're gonna you're gonna experience a
couple different things potentially
there may be some you know cities
running dry in a certain sense but
they're going to prioritize this by
having higher prices so they may bring
in fuel from other areas to supplement
those that are running low and try and
make sure there's kind of like a triage
going on so ultimately the most likely
scenario is just higher gas prices it's
not the end of the world and besides if
you're really concerned about five
dollar gallon gases buy a Tesla it's
only sixty thousand dollars so you know
problems solved right there on the low
end 160 000 if you want the high end but
you know and that's reasonable for the
average American you know just to spend
160 Grand on a car might as well before
inflation makes it you know not valuable
anything you know what's that remember
that Dan Aykroyd I think it was Dan
Aykroyd joke it's SNL he's like
inflation's great don't you want to
smoke hundred dollar cigars wear a five
thousand dollar suit drive a ten
thousand dollar or what do you say like
thirty thousand dollar car or something
it was the 70s but but also just to
continue this story on there's a lot of
other problems ahead of us particularly
because we're just entering right now
the high demand season for diesel and a
lot of people use it for heat and so far
we had a mild fall we're entering into a
mild winter but but if winter gets
severe a lot of people are going to be
using diesel needing it to heat their
homes uh a lot of the country a lot of
the trucks a lot of the farming a lot of
the infrastructure is run on diesel so
with the refineries and imports slowing
down and the demand increasing yes the
price is going to go up dramatic
medically from here and hopefully we
could avoid an utter tragedy from
unfolding here but this is uh this
year's problem it's expected to get
worse the second year the third year as
of course this is something that isn't
going to be fixed anytime soon as the
conflict between Russia and the West has
of course been escalating and with those
escalations there are consequences this
is one of them a diesel shortage we had
a super chat before the show started so
I just want to let everybody know if you
super chat before we go live YouTube
erases those super chats but it was from
someone named D lamb who mentioned that
the person who delivers like I guess
heating oil was that what it was he said
they can't guarantee the supply over the
winter yeah in the UK we heard the exact
same thing the BBC is secretly preparing
messages for when there's energy
shortages like blackouts or something
and they're saying they that there may
be rationing or shortages of fuel for
heating people's homes in the winter uh
mind you they said at the beginning of
December Not only living to the
Christmas holiday so December yeah yeah
you can get well uh like upside down
Planters pots those clay pots and then
you cut a little hole in the top and you
put candles inside of them they create
like heat yeah like holds the Heat and
then makes like a like a little bit of
the heat radiator and then you put like
layers of them so you put a larger
planter on top of a smaller planter and
you can get a lot of ambient heat for if
you don't have heat and also I don't
know how important it is but don't they
use diesel to transport diesel yeah yeah
yeah yeah it's a compounding compounding
problem and gasoline and and basically
everything so if there's a shortage of
diesel it means you might not have
eggnog or sour cream or whatever it is
you're trying to get for the Christmas
holidays well isn't that convenient
though I mean because we're saving the
world right now so you mentioned the
candle and the pot and stuff I mean
that's just good for the environment
anyway yeah you know I'm I mean this is
what it's all about we should be
figuring isn't that convenient right how
to survive next you know what we should
do let's start let's let's look up how
to catch rabbit and then and then I
learned this I think it uh uh who told
us this when you're eating rabbit you
got to make sure you crack the bones and
and get the fat out of the marrow
because you know otherwise it's called
rabbit starvation they don't have enough
fat in them so you can't just eat rabbit
but with the bone marrow you should be
good fat numb it sounded like an element
a large segment of the world Heats their
homes with kerosene right now and it
causes massive like uh lung problems
because they're breathing in the black
smoke so I think candles might on a you
know if you if you scale it up cause
something like problem like that you
don't want to breathe in Candle smoke
um especially though people resorting to
kerosene it could be a big big problem
you gotta make sure things are
especially scented candles you don't
want those extra synths you know bug
anus yeah it's one of my favorites I've
been thinking about the policies of Joe
Biden the administration Democrats and
you know what's the what's all the fuss
about I'm not poor it's the poor people
who have to suffer under Democrats and
they voted for him so you know I I
advocated to help you know people but uh
they they get to root what they sow and
then we can all uh um you know sit back
and and sit atop our balconies drinking
fine wine in the Ivory Tower right looks
down for that I don't know about that
that's not really true but you know I
have a better idea why don't we just try
surf Dum I think that's going to really
help the planet and you know we might as
well just serve the monarchy and the
ruling Elites and just base our lives on
providing for them you know I think
that's a really nice idea good point
though but think about this right what's
going to happen to your average company
when the economy completely collapses
the I mean the people are going to have
no choice but to become serfs right like
if you own the company you basically
become an oligarch you know so the
economy collapses there's no resources
and then all of the all the working
pores come to you and say please help us
and then you go oh the pause want my
food and uh you know as long as you're
hanging out Democrats they got a plan
for this I'd imagine because they're the
ones who made this all possible I love
that the the pores has made its way back
into the cultural conversation yeah Elon
Musk is going to give the Poor's access
to verification oh yeah well I thought
we were in a um in a uh transition
because didn't Biden say that like the
the gas shortage was part of the
transition at some point like a few
months ago yeah so so is it on purpose
is it like not on purpose to get serious
with it and you know I I just
I can't believe people voted for this
and there's a certain point where I
understand the people who are watching
and listening to the show like this you
didn't vote for it you voted against it
you voted to protect yourselves you
voted for protecting the lives of your
family your friends and making the world
better and then the Democrat voters who
voted in the Biden Administration other
Democrats voted on hatred with no real
plan a man who's not all there and it's
just making everything substantially
worse and the scary thing is they're
going to vote for fetterman they're
going to vote for more of these
Democrats despite I mean this is
fascinating I was reading this article
on why we're going to see this Red Wave
even in New York where the safe Democrat
areas are almost flipping Republican now
and they said I think it was uh it was
time I'm sorry was it New York Times
sang
you have Democrats right now campaigning
on abortion and Maga when crime is up
like 40 and gas prices are through the
roof and Republicans are campaigning on
these issues like we're gonna get your
gas prices down and deal with crime and
the Democrats just say but don't you
want to abort your kids and the people
are like I don't care I'm hungry dude I
need to drive my car so now all of a
sudden in New York there's one poll
showing Lee zeldin is beating hokel
Republic we could have Republican
Governor so you're saying the country is
not going to be voting for The Biden
administration's policies because they
support Dylan Mulvaney you say Dylan
movini is not as popular to Galvanize
the American public to make them support
this Administration and the amazing work
they're doing in society while
destroying everything else uh again it's
absolutely crazy what's happening here
and another aspect that we should really
try to understand here is that the gas
prices right now the diesel prices right
now are at a price with the government
doing a lot of things behind the scenes
artificially trying to keep those prices
down just a couple of days ago just a
couple weeks ago Biden went to Saudi
Arabia and literally begged the Empire
to produce more oil up until the midterm
elections Saudi Arabia said nope we're
not going to be doing that we're
actually going to tell everyone your
plan and screw you over as you're
pushing for of course a Green Revolution
that will essentially screw over Saudi
Arabia in the long term but but again
what else is the government doing right
now to keep these prices low what are
they going to be doing after the
election when they don't care that's
going to be another big impact factor
here when it comes to the price of gas
and Diesel going up I gotta say you know
uh we're we're one week away from the
actual midterm election day votes are
already coming in we just had the
libertarian candidate endorse the
Republican in Arizona for Senate which
is crazy Masters and I kind of feel like
whatever you think about 2018 and 2020
with the Democrats winning you can only
fool the people for so long when you try
to crank up gas prices take away energy
production generally make things worse
because you have some weird cult
ideology about the world ending
eventually a regular person says you
know I'm done I don't care I just want
you to guess
so they can do whatever they want they
can say whatever they want they can play
whatever dirty games they can Riot they
can scream and eventually someone just
says I can't pay gas I'm voting for the
other guy
we'll see we'll see you know you don't
want to count your chickens before they
hatch but uh
even Joe Rogan said the Red Wave that's
coming is going to look like the
elevator doors opening in The Shining
it's going to just flood through and
there are some projections this it may
be substantially worse than even the
projections are making it out because
right what's happening is Real Clear
Politics 538 they're tracking all these
polls and they're like look at this
Republicans are up one point that
predicts we're going to see you know
this many seats in Congress then you
factor in that the pole stars are all
completely wrong and they're off by like
7 to 13 points and it there's there's
some scenarios 538 presented where
Republicans can have like 260 seats in
the house just absolutely 56 seats in
the Senate
I don't know about all that but you tell
me that Diesel's running out and I'd say
okay you give me the day before the
election gas at five bucks a gallon and
everyone is just being like no no don't
care Republican just whoever is not in
charge right now yeah it's funny because
Biden said just the other day that
that's how much gas was when he took
office he couldn't even remember that
gas was actually half that price when he
took office so or he's lying or he's
lying or he just yeah or he's often
Never Never Land but I think that people
are getting pushed to that point now
where they've they voted just because
they were sort of conditioned for four
or five years to take whoever it was
going to be on the other side and now
they're sort of facing the backlash of
that where you you can't afford food and
gas the two you know or a roof over your
head for crying out loud so yeah I mean
I don't know what they're thinking we
saw what happened in France when they
added that tax on petrol which increased
the price by only like a dime or
something it was two years of Rights
basically they have to understand that
if they want to carry through their
weird climate change agenda great reset
whatever you want to call it
you put people homeless in the streets
and we're seeing more and more homeless
people this is probably why eventually
you have just disorder and Chaos are
they are they hoping for this do they
think that Civilization is going to pull
through and people don't have a place to
live and they're starving now those
people are going to get mad they're
going to smash windows and take stuff I
guess that's what they want how do you
how do you look at those cities and vote
for more of it the conditions of it
right now the last time I was in San
Francisco you could smell the urine in
the air and it's gotten worse since I
mean New York's not too dissimilar New
York what sour milk like you walk
through Midtown and just you get a whiff
of sour milk periodically and roasted
nuts and roasted nuts that's true too it
smells fantastic if you're lucky yeah if
you're lucky but it's like giving it's
back and forth sometimes you're in
depending on where you are but now we've
got all the crazy Subway crime you see
this stuff in New York City where people
are getting pushed in front of trains
some dude got stabbed kids are getting
robbed and uh
the Democrats are campaigning on
abortion I feel like cleaning the Earth
is something that we do when we're
stabilized like if we're at war or in a
state of chaos we're just gonna do be
doing what we need to do to survive and
producing waste as the byproduct until
we find a place of peace and stability
where we can go back and clean up all
the waste like waste management is very
low on the real life living survival
priority thing so if for to cut out
people's fuel supply and then expect us
to like peacefully transition into a
state of like green energy is not it
doesn't logically transmute for me I
don't think peaceful is the way we're
going let's jump to this next story from
Forbes alleged Paul Pelosi attacker
pleads not guilty to State charges David
de Papa the man accused of bluntly
attacking Paul Pelosi Nancy's husband
pleaded not guilty Tuesday to attempted
murder and other state charges according
to several reports as authorities allege
de Pape specifically targeted the
pelosis and aimed to hold the house
Speaker hostage
uh I'm just going to pause and I don't
believe any of it I don't know what to
believe there's a lot of really crazy
stories I don't believe the the the gay
orgy story I think that's a little too
extreme maybe the people are like
speculating as to why he was there but
the narrative keeps changing for
whatever reason the police are the media
reports are changing too rapidly on this
one for me to understand at all what
happened so here we have a story of some
weird goings-on that's about it I don't
know what do you guys think what do you
think happened why don't they just
release the security footage so we can
all just know what happened because I
didn't they come out saying that there
was no security footage because I
actually went back I found from 2020
there was an article article that came
out uh early January their their house
had been attacked and they're like
security footage was you know on there
and and they don't release it now they
and they said they reported the police
had body camera footage I'm hearing a
bunch of crazy stuff that an unknown
person opens the door then they said
actually that's not true then they said
when they came in they saw Pelosi and de
Pape fighting over a hammer now some
people are reporting that Pelosi himself
opened the door then they said he was in
his underwear now they're saying he
wasn't in his underwear like like what's
up yeah yeah how do you mess that up
it's like the bin Laden raid he was
wearing long like long johns is that
what they're called is that what they're
doing well we didn't mean underwear we
meant long johns tidy whities
[Laughter]
with the butt flap yes when Paul called
the cops he mentioned David by name is
this this is what I've heard yes so he
knew the guy so if he knows this guy
then that guy has knew that he was
Nancy's husband I'm thinking this is my
story that I've got in my head Paul's
got some dealer Paul's a crazy dude wild
man you know much love Paul whatever I
don't care I'm not going to judge you on
that so you got this guy coming over
your house at two in the morning
he knows that it's Nancy Pelosi's
husband so he's stewing this Paul guy or
this uh David guy stewing with his
Stoner friends and they're doing all
sorts of drugs out in the East you know
I know these people from La like I I
lived with these people they get crazy
are you Ian no do dirty hippies can go
crazy for The psychosis too much weed
they do a lot of drugs and Other Drugs
um and so they're like this guy very
well may have issues with Nancy Pelosi
he's like I'm gonna do it tonight's the
night and he goes over there and he gets
all freakish and like but I think that
they knew each other I think that he
would and and that they're gonna they're
gonna throw this guy under the bus
they're gonna try and throw this guy on
the bus for terrorism charges when it
turns out like Paul was probably like
he's probably Paul's dealer or or some
kind of like relation to Paul Paul knew
his name you don't just get rid you
don't know random attackers names when
they come into your house yeah well so
so we have updates from political here's
what they say five new details Paul
Pelosi told police he woke up with the
attacker in the room the speaker's
husband was asleep in his bedroom When
de Pape broke in through a glass door
entered into man to speak to Nancy
Pelosi according to the affidavit no
security was present at the time I I got
to ask why that is I mean this is this
is Pelosi Paul was wearing a pajama
shirt and boxers and the attacker
arrived Jenkins said he appeared
surprised to see the men in his room
according to a police account based on
an interview with the papay this is why
you have guns and why we believe in the
Second Amendment because
um you you wake up in this strange man
in your room with you know threatening
you and you're armed you have a lot less
to worry about
San Francisco police officers found
supplies in a backpack the Bape carried
zip ties tape rope a pair of rubber and
cloth gloves a journal and at least one
hammer with him to the pelosium so there
were two hammers according to the
affidavit law enforcement also seized a
sword and two hammers in the garage
where the papay lived interesting so
this is a uh this is almost like the
Kavanaugh story except the Kavanaugh guy
got apprehended yep de Pape told police
he was like the country's Founders after
Paul Pelosi informed him the speaker was
at home de Pape said he would sit and
wait for several days for her to arrive
the affidavit said and when Pelosi tried
to use a phone housed in an in-home
elevator to call the police depape
blocked him an in-home elevator oh I'm
impressed not surprised though de Pape
also did not leave after plus he called
9-1-1 because he felt that much like the
American founding fathers of the British
he was fighting against tyranny without
the option of surrender according to
Papa's statement to San Francisco police
alleged threat to break her kneecaps
devape told police intended to take the
speaker hostage talked to her and break
her kneecaps if she lied let's do the
nuts
de Papa said in a police statement he
wanted to lure someone else he wanted to
use Nancy to lure another individual
they have David said the document
doesn't say who the other other
individual might have been but Bobby
told police in the same statement that
he viewed Pelosi as the leader of the
pack of Lies told by the Democratic
party it's really weird that a guy can
live in a house with a black lives
matter sign in the window a pride flag
this house rejects hate sign and then
all of a sudden just be a you know
Auntie he could be a Maga guy how about
this many of these leftists also hate
Nancy Pelosi it's really that simple I'm
not buying there wasn't any security
yeah I don't think anyone is yeah how is
that possible that Pelosi would have no
security that's crazy they have dudes
that hang out in front of their house
like all day I mean you you pointed this
out we have security and we're not third
in line or right anywhere near
government or you know one of the
richest people in the world mysteriously
under of course very lucky circumstances
that the Pelosi's are under yeah but but
this is an attack again that the media
is using as it's galvanizing push for
more online censorship for the
destruction of speech and with Elon Musk
just buying Twitter this is the topic
that a lot of people are discussing and
the corporate media is running the
narratives information conspiracy
theories bad people having free speech
bad because it leads to these situations
that happen with uh Paul Pelosi and
that's disingenuous and it's absolutely
you know has no credibility to it when
you actually look at the facts of the
situation here well Roscoe read up a
good point in super chats he said maybe
the same CCT company that did the prison
Epstein was in did the Pelosi residence
or uh and probably I think it was the
same company that did the Pentagon
surveillance uh on on 911 as well that
had all the security cameras everywhere
oh that's a great bit yeah on the
security company for the intelligence
agencies and it's like yeah yeah exactly
you guaranteed to shut down during an
emergency they have like a button they
can press that just like creates an
error you can automatically crash your
system with a press of a button and it
looks like a total breakdown or or they
can be like actually serious like we're
the best security and then this happened
to accidentally you know fail all the
time at critical moments just when you
need the most to fail well they'll be
there for you they're saying there's
body camera footage of this yeah Tucker
Carlson asked for it they said no yeah
just put it out yeah then
I'm actually on board with this as long
as they have the evidence and they're
not releasing it I am going to just have
to believe then it was a gay orgy yeah
that's right three guys I got so much
more fun isn't it well so look there was
a third guy according to police report
they're changing airport yeah but but
look
if if you're refusing to release the
evidence showing us what really happened
right well then I'm gonna assume the
worst I'm gonna assume Paul Pelosi was
look I don't know the gay orgy thing I
think he's trying to buy drugs I really
do that that is likely that night it
could have been David just going over
and he's like David what the hell what
are you doing here at 2 A.M and David's
like I want to talk to Nancy's tweaking
out of his mind and Paul get out of here
maybe but no security no he had a third
guy open the door the cops don't just
say that on accident if that was the
report there's a third guy a third
person then there was a third person
then who owns someone went and asked him
to change the report the third right
right security at guard who knows yup
yup because this isn't maybe security
guard maybe and then they were like well
then how did this guy break in if
there's a security they let him in
because they know him probably exactly
the guy's local in the area knew him
here's what I think dude's probably a
dealer because they said that he like
they say that you know I don't know I
heard the dudes a druggie or something
Paul Pelosi calls him up he comes over
and he's like you got the stuff yes and
then David says it's it's it costs I'll
tell you what happened David goes it's
50 bucks now and Paul goes 50 bucks it
was 35 yesterday it was inflation what
do you expect and he's like I'm not
spending 50 bucks I came all the way
down here give me my 50 bucks I have
stocks to buy they got getting into it
and they're fighting security guards
like what's going on then he's like I'm
gonna call the police unless you get out
of here I'm done with you and he's like
call him see if I care do it I dare you
and then he calls him and he's like yeah
there's a strange guy in my house and
then a fight breaks out third guy's like
I don't know what's going on no no I
don't know about that I'm I'm mostly
kidding but you make a good point Ian
you don't accidentally say a third
person open the door yeah that makes no
sense right that was very intentionally
that there's a third person there that's
what the cops said honestly this idea
that this far leftist dude had a radical
transformation into a q Anon Maga guy
come on that's crazy well you know I was
thinking about that because there's a
famous clip of uh Pelosi she's talking
about smear campaigns and how you just
put out the wrong story up front so by
the time the truth comes out nobody
cares anymore and so that's what I think
this is is they're just put out the
smear campaign for their own political
purposes it doesn't matter clearly but I
can't I just I find it really hard to
believe that this this reminds me of
like the craziness of the Alec Baldwin
story because we talked a lot about how
the the scenario for Alec Baldwin to
have accidentally killed that woman is
like winning the lottery three times in
a row like accidentally doesn't check
the gun after Decades of of training on
set accidentally it's loaded with live
ammo he accidentally points it at her
accidentally pulls the hammer back
accidentally pulls the trigger like come
on like all of those things you know
it's possible I guess but the simple
story is actually just he pointed it and
shot it like why didn't he check that so
I look at this story and I'm like okay
you want me to believe
that if far leftist who lives in a house
with a BLM with a BLM sign a pride flag
a hippie leftist with stickers on the
bus in their parking space that has a
bunch of leftists like pro pro liberal
Democrat stuff in San Francisco in
Berkeley or San Francisco or was it
Berkeley that's interesting I think he
lived in Berkeley and then this happened
in San Francisco Paul's house right
right right so I'm supposed to believe
this guy all of a sudden just had this
radical transformation to a trump
supporter even though he's a Canadian
illegal immigrant he has this radical
transformation
knows where the Pelosi's live shows up
there's no security is able to get in I
gotta believe all of those things for
the story to be true so yeah then I
gotta believe the police accidentally
said there's a third person they gotta
then I gotta believe they accidentally
report he was in his underwear are you
kidding me after all of those accidental
reportings I don't believe it I'm sorry
I want to know who did what happened who
he wants to talk to like he was like
Nancy's gonna be honest with me or else
I'll you know the threaten about her
kneecaps but like honest about what
what's going on here that sounds
personal sounds like they know each
other and then who's this other person
that he wants Nancy to like corroborate
something for another person like it
just sounds all like personal family
drama yeah it was pull up maybe it was
Pelosi's son's dealer maybe maybe it was
their son's dealer and he showed up
because he was like dude owes me money
security guard let him in because they
know him and then he went to he went to
Paul and said your son owes me money
you're gonna pay me no I'm not I don't
care what my son's doing and then he is
like apparently his son was there you
want to check this real quick wow and
he's probably like I'll go to the media
I'll tell everyone your son's doing a
bunch of drugs you don't want this kind
of information and then you know the
Pelosi's are like there's one way to
stop this story from going out there get
the hammer out yeah
get the double a batteries in there
immediately
he may have been there after the fact
but look I'll just say this if you want
me to believe a whole bunch of crazy
circumstances to believe your insane
story like that's conspiracy theory
territory dude a conspiracy that
far leftist hippie guy is radicalized
then then it bypasses security what did
he do was he like was he like uh you
know yippee Kaye climbing through the
air vents Die Hard style got inside the
building this is ridiculous
I think it's you know you know it's
plausible
son owes him money for drugs
he shows up the house security guard
says hey man how's it going lets him in
Junior's not there goes to the dad hey
you owe me money Paul your kid's not
paying me you're paying me he's like get
on my house I'm not paying you anything
then he's like if you don't leave I'm
gonna call the cops and that's how it
happens then the third guy opens the
doors security guy was like leave me out
of it then they're like how do we
explain this to the press that there was
a drug deal gone wrong or something I
don't buy the official story it doesn't
make it doesn't make sense isn't that
funny that the stories we keep getting
are all like this we all have to talk
about it and figure out the nooks and
crannies of it ourselves without just
getting the story like the Alec Baldwin
story too yeah like every single time
every week every day there's a new story
and we're like well here's here's like
uh 10 of the story but we're not going
to say this is this is important right
here because someone's super chatted
Cosmic Cosmic surgeon said I've sold a
lot of drugs but never in my underwear
dude wasn't even in his underwear
apparently that's what I'm saying and he
had a backpack
so I don't I don't I don't buy the story
man guy gets radicalized the cops get
the story completely wrong I I just
looked at him and I assumed that blue
jeans and a t-shirt was underwear whoops
the third guy actually same guy if there
was no third guy who opened the door for
you it was uh Paul Pelosi but he was
fighting with the guy with a hammer yes
so he's fighting with the guy with the
hammer makes his way they both wiggle
over the door he opens it for you as
he's fighting this is insane come on
I'll tell you this I get it we don't
know what happened how about you you
release the surveillance footage in the
body camera footage and then we'll all
know exactly what happened the story can
go away exactly I don't see how you
could prosecute this story without body
camera footage at this point we don't
use footage anymore for these stories
though I really ever footage ever so
Dave is the kind of things he's uh he
said he's innocent so he's he's going
declared innocent sorry he's pleading
innocent I wonder what his side of the
story well he's released that statement
so that's the other thing too it's like
he told police these things okay sure
I'm definitely down to look and I want
to hear him say it the challenge just
when the police have already gotten all
this stuff wrong expect me to believe
them the cops are like he was in his
underwear and a third third dude opened
the door oops never mind and now you
expect me to trust you when you say
here's what he told me yeah the crazy
guy said this last night I was thinking
I can't wait to hear David's side of the
story and then I got this like message
from God I got this impulse of like
there's no way we're letting him talk to
the public and that was from Paul Paul's
like there's no way we're letting David
talk to the public right now what if
they Epstein like what do you mean that
you're letting him this is all just like
in my in my imagination but I'm like is
this the kind of energy like is this
real are they like in control are they
in cahoots with the cops I don't see why
they wouldn't be the speaker of the
house or family local police like I
think they probably know each other
pretty well yeah first and foremost no
matter what I find it hard to believe
there was no security there yeah just
insane apparently that the Pelosi's have
safe house security is the company that
is uh Pelosi's private security well
there's also a neighborhood security
company too based on that story that I
found from 2020 there's a there's a
company that goes around for the
neighborhood itself then there's the
Pelosi security then they also have
security cameras so there's no reason
then they also have Capital police
officers that fly from Washington DC to
literally watch them at their home which
has been targeted politically before so
so it's just absolutely mind-boggling
they have no security come on let's talk
about suppression of information we have
the story from CNBC this website's
struggling to stay open Twitter
reportedly limits employee access to
content moderation tools as midterm
electioneers the move comes before the
midterms Elon Musk said on Friday he
will be take after taking control of
Twitter he plans to form a Content
moderation Council so this is this is
potentially big news whether it's
intentional or not so here's what we
have
according to Joel Roth I think his name
is this is normal for a company
transition after a sale the reason being
you got a bunch of disgruntled employees
they're about to be fired you lock
everybody out you keep only trusted
people to have access otherwise someone
goes what's up who cares cnbc's trash so
uh we know the story is happening
the issue is they're concerned about
company transition regardless of that
this means that right now Twitter is
effectively a free-for-all
it doesn't mean you can do whatever you
want because they are Banning people
Viva fry got suspended for like no real
reason but it just goes to show you the
machine's broken right now so people are
probably gonna build are going to be
able to post a lot of stuff though we
are seeing probably it may be worse
because now it's hyper automated
so you're going to be getting a lot of
weird stuff but but Biden himself got
fact checked that was really interesting
nice hey man right before a week before
the midterms heck of a time for this to
happen what do you think happens well
Dave Smith starts trending this is
processing yeah he's trending right now
oh what's he trending for I don't know
it's being awesome what did Biden say
that got fact checked he talked about
the inflation reduction act
um uh being an act that's going to allow
the mega corporations to be taxed and he
was fact checked being like well only
some of them might be taxed under this
new law maybe uh but he was saying we're
going to get more revenue for all these
huge companies in the billions of
dollars and then you know the fact check
was well so you got like a little tag on
underneath his post or what yeah I think
uh oh he's got a couple of them it's
it's not just this one he said some
seniors pay 400 bucks a month for
insulin it's ridiculous thanks to the
inflation reduction act where capping
that cost us 35 bucks a month and then
it says readers added context while the
inflation production act capped
inflation at 35 bucks for individuals on
Medicare it did not cap costs for
seniors on private insurance
out of the 8.4 million Americans take
insulin only 3.3 are covered by Medicare
and there's a bunch of these he's
getting fact checked a lot there was one
about taxing big corporations here you
go look at this one
let me give you the facts let me give
you the facts Jack in 2020 55
corporations made 40 billion and they
paid zero in federal taxes my inflation
reduction reduction act puts an end to
this
and then you get the fact check the
inflation reduction act imposes a
minimum tax on corporations with average
pre-tex earnings greater than a billion
out of the 55 corporations he references
only 14 had earnings greater than a
billion so he's full of it I don't know
I don't know maybe taking away Twitter
moderation tools from most the staff
just means that we're now going to see
Democrats and journalists on the left
actually start getting flagged it's
going to be interesting because
Bloomberg is reporting that only some of
the employees lost their access to
content moderation and policy
enforcement which ones uh what was this
about we don't know yet we don't know
the details here but there have been a
lot of people after Elon Musk that that
you know acquired Twitter that have been
censored like you afraid that you
mentioned that did get their accounts
back so I think I suspect well he got
his account back because he complied
with the BS takedown oh did he wow yeah
they said delete your Tweet you can come
back so we I'm pretty sure he did and
then said Fu because Elon Musk also uh
is sending out messages to people like
don't worry we'll help you soon he sent
a message to Michaela Peterson when she
reached out to him saying it's only
going to be in a matter of time we'll
fix the problems uh is the problem being
fixed now with some of these people
being taken away for for censoring
people for their political speech I I
think that is possibly What's Happening
Here uh but only time will tell it's
going to be interesting to see how this
moves forward especially with the
pressure from the federal government and
the DHS that of course wants to censor
speech that wants to limit the
conversations that people could have
naturally between themselves in a
Draconian totalitarian way what's going
to happen here is going to be
interesting you ready for the real good
news deadline says Hollywood's Twitter
Exodus who has quit who has threatened
to quit and he who refuses to leave so
uh there's a bunch of these stories
they're mentioning wrestling Legend Mick
Foley wrote I'll be giving some serious
thought to leaving blah blah blah but he
hasn't left I think that's the biggest
name there NBC news also had a very
similar article and I didn't know who
they were talking about I was like who
are these people they showed pictures of
four people I had no clue and no idea
who these people were oh
what's his name man mankind mankind yeah
a range of other prominent figures have
either threatened to quit Stephen King
signed off for a break which may or may
not be permanent Tony Braxton Teo Leone
Josh gadd Brian koppelman Alex Winter
and some expressed concerns Kara Swisher
or have definedly said they will stay in
fight Rob Reiner and George 10K the
funny thing is Eli on doesn't get it
Elon he doesn't get it commies don't
want to pay for things okay that's just
it so he can he can he can charge
whatever he wants to do once charge
they don't they don't even want to pay
for for they don't even they don't do
work they want free school they want
free everything and that just means you
pay for it they want to be on Twitter
they want to have verification they want
you to tell everyone how important they
are and they don't want to pay for it so
here's my advice to Elon let them go let
them Drift Away Into Obscurity we're
having a conversation over here on
Twitter that's where that's why George
Decay said I'm not leaving because he
gets it that's why I said Donald Trump
has no choice but to come back if they
reinstate them it's where the
conversation is
remember Will Wheaton when's the last
anyone's heard from him
you don't want to be active on these
platforms by off by by all means go
ahead and leave and then you know good
luck I'm not saying it's the end of the
world for these people I'm sure he's
doing something he's got a YouTube or
something going on and there have been
people on the right who have been banned
they still very much exist for sure Alex
Jones is doing his thing
but would if you if you willfully want
to remove yourself from the public
conversation go ahead and do it
there you go I almost did that last year
actually I went through this little
thing because of all the censorship it
was like well screw this I'm out of here
and I decided to stick with it and just
be more loud and more obnoxious and sort
of wait for them to just kick me out but
uh I think the thing is these people are
running from one from hearing another
Viewpoint you have one side of the aisle
that's like
I'm going to stay here and be loud and
and say what I want to say
shooting for truth Fighting For Freedom
uh but then you have other people that
don't want to hear it and that's why
they're leaving you know they're sort of
afraid that it's under the guise of hate
and uh intolerance and they don't want
to hear it so they're going to run but
then there's also this Eight dollar per
month uh inconvenience that but it's not
the final nail in the coffin so hey
would you rather a company be dependent
on the whims of multinational
corporations complying with the ESG
score or would you rather a company be
independently funded and not need to of
course bend over to of course the
globalist and the internationalists and
the corporations to me eight dollars a
month I'll gladly pay for it if Elon
Musk keeps his promise to protect free
speech and allow people to have their
political voices disseminated without
any uh you know destruction of those
voices without any kind of censorship so
so I'm willing I'm gladly willing to
have her Twitter blue for like four
dollars a month and that's basically
just gives you what it allows you to
upload it allows you to upload videos
that are a lot longer and it gives you
some analytics and that's four bucks a
month so Sarah Barella says welp it's
been fun I'm out see you on other
platforms peep sorry this one's just not
for me George alexopoula said who are
you
that's hilarious hey look she's got 2.8
million followers yeah but I have no
idea who she is she's cute
exactly Harmony
I still have no idea I have no clue but
but what's Happening Here I I'll bet
your bottom dollar right now that that
all these corporate media companies are
reaching out to all these celebrities
and saying hey are you hearing Mick
Foley might quit are you going to be
brave and quit too can we sign up your
name too to this article hey can can you
can you stand up against this bigotry
and this hatred are you going to do the
right thing and and say you're going to
get off Twitter once the hatred comes
back and they're of course calling all
these celebrities and trying to bait
them into pushing uh this larger attack
against Twitter and that's exactly
what's happening I want to tell you
who's Sarah Bareilles is
she is a Twitter user with 2.8 million
followers who can barely muster a couple
dozen retweets or likes on any of her
content yeah I mean all of her tweets no
engagement so see this is the
opportunity for a lot of these has beens
they have a lot of followers because
they gained a lot of followers for doing
something but now they're not relevant
anymore how do you make yourself
relevant standard to finally and say I
have almost three million followers and
I'm leaving well nobody nobody look look
this is my point though see how she gets
like no retweets anywhere 31 wow 31 30
19 but hold on when she says I'm leaving
six thousand with 40 000 replies 75 000
likes it's just PR that's all it is it's
it's it's it's a it's a it's a yeah but
the bigger question is how many of those
followers are real she's not getting any
engagement did she buy any followers is
there no an artificial boost to this no
no no no no no what happens is someone
like Sara Bareilles she has that big
song I'm not going to write you a love
song or whatever she has other songs
sure people listen she probably gets a
ton of traffic on Spotify but that song
was really big when that comes out she's
in the Press everywhere tons of people
then follow her but for no reason no
one's following her to listen to her
opine on her politics
so when it comes to actual engagement
they don't they don't engage for people
like us
that people follow us and we follow
others for the conversation not her so
she can't get any engagement a ton of
followers it's useless for her so what
does she do now is a chance to to get in
the news what happens she's in she's in
the store she's in deadline
congratulations you made the Press
a platform that you had no engagement on
that no one cared to listen to you and
you could use that to boost your your
your status it's the same thing with um
I saw another article and it had a list
of like celebrities on that level where
it was like oh I know them from that one
thing like Alex Winter from Bill and Ted
was leaving and he's in the list now so
it's like everybody got the memo and
everybody made their statement and
they're like I can't do it I'm out and
so then now you're seeing Alex Winter
who's oh oh yeah that guy Sarah
barrielle who's that oh yeah that song
yeah yeah yeah I should check that song
out that was a good song Toni Braxton
she tweeted I'm shocked and appalled at
some of the Free Speech I've seen on
this platform since its acquisition hate
speech under the veil of free speech is
unacceptable therefore I am choosing to
stay off Twitter as it is no longer a
safe space for myself my sons and other
POC Heavens please Tony keep your
children indoors at all times heaven
forbid they go outside and hear a
naughty word of a random person walking
down the street the first response here
is hilarious by Ron Coleman right there
the GIF of people laughing in their face
do you know how much terrible stuff is
on Twitter that apparently they were
never ever really worried about prior to
you all right thank you there's porn
there's hardcore porn on Twitter right
now and you're like well now it's not a
safe space right there's radical
jihadism there's people getting their
heads chopped off there's crime there's
like Gore some brutal videos all on the
platform of course no problem there's no
there's no problems with with that yeah
but this is too much we got to write
down the lucasms of course I'm gonna
create my own language here but but
anyway like you go on there
keep going uh you go on there and then
this is the issue people people just and
it hasn't even really started yet we're
not seeing a big change to the platform
yeah yeah nothing happened and these
people are freaking out that they're
leaving okay this is why
you know Elon is going to learn the hard
way that
he he mentioned this a while back that
he hopes to create a balance it's not
about making any one side happy it's
about making everybody you know
compromise he doesn't get it we are the
compromise we are the ones who are
outright saying these people advocate
for violence they are psychotic they dox
people and we are willing to say okay
fine let them have their awful opinions
and do their thing we'll mind our own
business they say no either ban them or
we walk that's what Will Wheaton did he
said if you don't ban Alex Jones I'll
quit and then they didn't then he quit
but then they eventually banned him
anyway
Elon
there is no compromise with with these
obstinate Psychopaths acting like all of
a sudden now the platform is dangerous
for her sons she has no problem with
like the murder videos that are on
Twitter there's war footage of people
being blown up I have seen videos of
people writhing on the ground with blood
spraying out of their body on this
platform I have seen videos of jets
dropping bombs I have seen videos of
white phosphorus and she's all of it
it's fake good luck Elon man can we talk
about this don't say we didn't work I'm
reading it and I'm thinking it's Toni
Braxton really sitting around reading
other people's tweets at home and and
what is in her news feed that is making
all this hate speech pop up because we
all sort of see what we are given to see
based on our own activity
you know I'm imagining her son comes in
it's like you know a month ago mom yeah
what is it I just watched a video of a
radical jihadist if you had somebody
yeah that's nice that's nice yeah then
he comes in a week later he's like Mom
Mom I'm watching two adults engage in uh
yeah yeah whatever that's nice then
she's sitting there reading the news
like Elon Musk buys Twitter no no no no
this is not safe for my sons yeah yeah
spare me dude it's it's all of them
though yeah Sara Bareilles doesn't care
about this stuff they're just at some
point Elon you gotta recognize tell them
to go away go away get get out of here
if I go outside right now if I go
downtown to like any big city you're
going to see some of the craziest stuff
people will be holding up pictures of
dead babies they're gonna be holding up
pictures of all sorts of nonsense
they're going to be screaming all sorts
of nonsense there's people who walk
around naked at Pride events they're
people there's there are performers in
Times Square who who get really close to
being naked you go to Hollywood you
might see some nudity all over the place
you're definitely going to see violence
hey if you literally go to New York City
you might get pushed onto the tracks
better keep your kids indoors lock the
room don't let them out because if
that's the reality you're scared of some
mean words that haven't even appeared on
the platform yet well okay then then you
shouldn't be going outside at all don't
make me have to pay for your fear nobody
in their right mind should be letting
their kids on Twitter without their
oversight oh no don't let your kids on
Twitter just don't give you you take
away their step one don't let your kid
up on Twitter
it's a Fray man it is The Fray it is it
is culture War Battle Zone yeah
I mean maybe take them on Twitter with
you to show them how crazy it is but
well Twitter needs to have like a safe
mode and not safe mode and that solves a
lot of the problems like that's what
mines does right yeah yeah so for work
stuff yeah you can have a safe mode
which is kind of like you know there's
some new stuff on it that's probably not
appropriate for kids but it's not really
that crazy and then there's the not safe
for work stuff which is war combat
serious crimes politics in my opinion a
lot of politics I don't know though I
think kids are allowed to listen to
politics and to a certain resp to a
certain degree I think most politics
probably fine most politics used to be
like this tax policy or you know things
like that I used to say religion wasn't
safe for work any kind of religious
stuff and then I'd get like Christmas
posts and I'd be like
all right by my own rules this is not
safe for work and it'd be like Holly
Jolly jingle and I'm like it's too
religious it's Christian are you yeah it
just stuck to my morals and I kept all
not safe for work if it's religious not
safe for work because not everyone's
Christian but it is safe for work but
it's not it's not something I want to to
appear on someone's computer in a work
environment because I don't want to
create divisiveness but why what's the
purpose of it like any kind of religion
this is their world view bro yeah our
world view is kind of like oh hey a post
about uh um you know Judaism
whatever I'll read it I'm interested in
seeing what they have to say I'm not
Jewish oh hey look Kwanzaa what's that
all about I'll read about that what do
you think Mormonism you know South Park
did a great episode on Mormonism where
they're kind of like ragging on the
Mormon faith and at the end of the
episode the Mormon family is just like
you know what we've been really nice to
you you guys are just dicks like the
Mormon family was really nice and
wholesome and didn't hurt anybody but
they believed things that the other kids
thought were stupid
um that's how I see it you post
something on on social media and I think
it's dumb whatever man if I disagree
with you I disagree with you that's the
conversation if it's like someone saying
if if I see like a a post about BLM or
something and it's it's it's in the uh
it's in the context of hey look at this
young man who was killed by police in
this story it's really sad I'm not gonna
be like screw you morons I'm gonna be
like whatever you know yeah we shouldn't
be trying in to appease uh deranged
children who never grew up like these
individuals put them in a safe space put
a play put play foam in there Pat the
walls up and make it a virtual safe
space where people could go and they
will prioritize feelings over facts and
then have a real place where adults
could go that could have serious
conversations Ed could handle the
realities of this world and not need to
be safeguarded from the truth so so this
is what Elon Musk has been talking about
doing he also has been talking about
sharing advertisement revenue and
revenue from Twitter giving it to some
of the content creators he's planning to
officially lay off 25 of the company so
this is going to be a very big
transition that we're going to be seeing
here and I think he's gonna at the end
of the day offer people the opportunity
hey have your little safe space you know
be able just to see Disney cartoons and
and commercials for big Pharma being
regurgitated to you could have that
space you could make and then you could
have a real world space they could make
Twitter invite only nodes
he could say that someone like uh you
know Sara Bareilles can choose elect to
create a node which will give anyone who
follows her an invite to join the node
and the note is only her followers no
one can see anything inside of it or
share anything outside of it unless
they're invited to the node how about
that have you seen the tribal social
yeah yeah yeah like why aren't why
aren't they all flocking on over there A
lot of them are you know but here's the
issue The Daily Beast wrote that tribal
social is full of hate speech they're
going after tribal the same as they go
after parlor why because face CIA book
and Twitter you know actively cool with
government and the real advantage to
these centralized networks is the
manipulation of public opinion getting
everybody to go to tribal social is just
as bad as if it's parlor you lose
control of the narrative there you go
that makes sense
let's jump to this next story let's talk
about censorship
Chris pavlovsky tweeted the French
government has demanded that Rumble
block Russian news sources like Elon
Musk I won't move our goal posts for any
foreign government Rumble will turn off
France entirely France isn't material to
us and we will challenge the legality of
this demand
uh Chris why why even turn off Rumble in
France just ignore them what can they do
you're not in France if people in France
type in rumble.com that's on the people
of France let the government of France
block the website like the Chinese
Communist Party would and then we'll
talk about it how about that
yeah
yeah
that sounds like a great idea sounds
like an awesome idea I mean government's
trying to control information right now
during war is something that they have
always done historically but I I think
it's fair to say that you know we're
reaching a level where information
Warfare is being galvanized and used
against the best interest of the general
public and if France is going to be
going after you know Russian news
sources they should be going after all
the other news sources that are also
leading to damage leading to harm if
they truly were trying to do this
equally but they're not so uh shout out
to rumble for for standing in their
ground for allowing free speech to
thrive and and at the end of the day
people should be able to hear both sides
of the story and make up their opinions
but the thing is when you're when you're
pushing an agenda when you're fighting a
war when you want to kill somebody you
can't allow that in some instances and
that's the big bigger battle that I
think is being described here I think
it's amazing uh Elon Musk tweeted in
March that starlink had been told by
some governments to block Russian news
sources in the United States there's an
effort to try and shut down a lot of
these Russian news sources they ban
people like crazy Lee Camp he worked for
RT he had his own independent podcast
unrelated RT they banned that too
they're redacted tonight it wasn't
rejected tonight that guy they shut down
all of the shows but he had a separate
podcast that was like his own creation
and they banned that we should have him
on the show sometime I like well I've
reached out to him I don't know I've hit
him up several times cool guy but yeah
they shut him down they they shut him
down and a bunch of other people who
worked for RT started getting banned
like crazy it's just it's Chinese
Communist Party level psychotic behavior
I always liked RT during the war on
terror 2008 9 10 I'd be like what in the
hell actually is going on if Saddam
didn't have weapons of mass destruction
like why are we there RT was nice
because it was an outside perspective
and uh Al Jazeera because it was like
they would talk about American troop
movements and stuff that like NBC didn't
talk NBC's like we got him Osama Bin
Laden remember that guy you thought we
killed before we didn't but we got him
now and you're like oh okay okay okay
and then you know so it's good to get
outside perspectives um but like you
said they don't want you to have it dude
yeah in a time of War
I mean no I mean that was war and well
we were told the issue is the war on
terror yeah right the United States is
quickly becoming authoritarian over the
past six or so years the left is
screaming Donald Trump Donald Trump but
he's barely done anything it's like he
wouldn't even call in the the troops to
shut down the mass rioting around the
country
but what they've been doing with like
sisa working with Twitter and Facebook
to censor information and shut down
speech and actively they've been Banning
news outlets I mean how do you justify
legally constitutionally the shutting
down of a news Outlet in the U.S RT
they did
I think RT chose to shut itself down
right they like they terminated
operations because they were getting
banned or something like that was that
uh Russia Today yeah it's been it's been
a minute since the story broke but I
don't look man
the United States is becoming very much
a despotic regime like the Communist
Chinese party dude they created the war
on terror it's the most generic title
imagine if they created the war on evil
do you think that they'll ever do that
then we're gonna get to a point where
they'll be like and enough people will
be like zealous and they'll be like yeah
yeah Evil's bad we gotta fight it
fascism the war on fashion the war on
carbon the war on chaos you know they're
gonna be like the war on evil
they're going to be like are you carbon
uh I don't know I think he's carbon get
him and they're gonna it's just so like
it's so subjective what's terrorism if
people were gonna fight for the war on
evil they would we would have seen him
step up sooner the last three years
they're preparing people for some dumb
it's just so generic like it's just it's
just a reason to Rally people into
fighting to accepting curtailing rights
and empowering military-industrial
complex to build bigger bombs more
explosive and deadly weapons uh if they
just call it I mean it wasn't even a war
it wasn't a war it was a extra military
going on isn't it I think that it's
winding down yeah I don't know but they
can use terrorism ever since the Patriot
Act in these the NDA was signed they can
use like Terror as like they're talking
about this David Pat guy they're gonna
hit him with terrorism charges or so
they want to
I don't like it man they could you hit
what do they what are they charged you
with evil like could you imagine a
reality like you're going to jail what'd
I do evil you committed to evil soon
it's coming who decides if it's Terror
who decides if it's evil yeah Whoever
has the guns well that's I mean yeah
when antifa goes around for political
reasons terrorizing people they never
charge them with terrorism and they
should have yeah if they want to play
judiciously then it should have been
terrorism too but in that argument they
might have to start charging themselves
with terrorism when they drop bombs on
schools and stuff true but domestically
antifa putting on masks there's a video
out of I think it's Portland OR Seattle
they they're marching through
neighborhoods they see a house that
American flag so they stop they go to
his house knock on the door and start
threatening the guy like this is
Terrorism yeah okay these people should
be charged because they're they're
marching around in gangs with with
weapons and threatening people if you
want to March around in a mask with a
gun I don't I don't care at all you want
to March around with a mask and a gun
and then walk up to a house where guys
got an American flag and threaten him
you cross the line you want to walk down
the street by yourself with a pink
pullover you know collared shirt and
khakis and then knock on the door of
someone with an American flag and
threaten them you've crossed the line
right allowing people who are armed to
point guns at people in the street like
they were doing and getting away with it
without charging them for anything
that's how you know it's just it can
only get it can only get worse from here
I suppose
well they were doing it mostly
peacefully though fiery but peaceful
fiery and that's in that remarkable who
who buys this do you see uh it was a
clip from The View that went viral where
they're like these Republicans are the
ones celebrating violence it's like are
you nuts who's like you you get like
Glenn Beck Ben Shapiro Stephen Crowder
Tucker Carlson literally when have any
of the of the key prominent right-wing
individuals ever advocated or supported
violence they've not even when it came
to George Floyd Ben shapir is coming up
being like this is horrible I can't
believe this happened yeah when it comes
to the antifa riots kamalaris literally
fundraises for them the bite
Administration donates to bail these
people out they Advocate to get these
people out of jail and they defend them
and say but they're peaceful protesters
fiery you had those two people who
firebombed a cop car in New York and
they get like what like 18 months or
some some ridiculously low number and
then you get people who trespass the
capital and they get four to seven years
amazing
there you go you got to be careful with
my system charging people that because
like Terror if like you're scared
because of something I did it doesn't
mean that I'm terrorizing you just
because I'm behaving a certain way
doesn't mean that I'm Terror just
because you're feeling Terror like you
might have eaten have too much coffee
and now you're you're freaking out
because your adrenals are overloaded and
screaming like um he's a he's doing this
to me like so you want to protect
people's rights like you said you can
carry a weapon down the street and
you're okay to do that uh as long as
you're not aggressively going after
somebody
yeah well it depends where you're at in
New York City you can't even have a
pocket knife so they'll come and arrest
you that's that's the number one arrest
that they have in pocket knives yeah
yeah yeah that's that's the number I
heard that that the number one arrest in
New York City in Times Square is people
with pocket knives and police officers
just walk around trying to see who has
it and then they arrest individuals for
doing that constitutionally I should
clarify yeah again what's Happening Here
is people are trying to control the
narrative as I've been saying for a long
time and other people said it before me
the first casualty of war is the truth
and you want to of course have a
landscape right now where you're not
only just fighting in the in the real
world in Ukraine with the larger proxy
war but there's a bigger War also that's
an information War and what the French
government is trying to do here is is
One symptom of this larger war of them
trying to consolidate information
control that information so they could
use it for their own personal benefit
France is also in a very weird position
because uh you we have the Rothschild
Banker French president warning about
escalations in Ukraine saying hey we we
really got to stop it here we really
have to de-escalate the situations here
and now the French government is just
trying to ban any alternative version of
the story which of course is
predominantly done for their war that
they're trying to push as of course
France has been giving Aid to Ukraine so
so this kind of landscape is kind of
confusing and perplexing to see
especially with the larger relations and
the trade deals that just happened
between Russia and France so
um very complex point of view but there
are a lot of people that don't want you
seeing an alternative version of the
story and whether you agree with it or
not you should be able to see it for you
to judge it for yourself and I think if
we're able to do that we're able to
de-escalate a lot of the war efforts a
lot of the propaganda a lot of this
information that has brought us to the
situation where a lot of people are
fearing of full all-out nuclear war this
is a real reality that we're facing
mainly because of this one kind of
mentality and denying free speech and
just pushing a war mess message non-stop
which the corporate media does all the
time you look at all the messaging on
the corporate media it's always pro-war
there's no anti-war voices anymore on
the corporate media when there was they
got extinguished Jesse Ventura had a
huge contract with MSNBC he wanted to
speak out against the wars they
literally bought him off and said you
know what we know we paid you a lot of
money just shut up and sit down don't
say anything and we're not going to
publish your show golden handcuffs they
call it exactly and they did this to
Donahue they did this to Jesse Ventura
they did this to Cheng yuger of The
Young Turks right now on MSNBC because
they weren't toting the line and pushing
the military-industrial complex
propaganda and I think the more that we
could counteract the military-industrial
complex the propaganda the
disinformation the less likely we are to
have a full all-out nuclear World War a
World War they will offer you a big
contract and it'll be for something
legitimate like you'll make you know
appearances in the show we'll have you
as a correspondent
Etc and then if you don't say what the
machine wants you to say it serves a
great benefit to have you on under
contract where you can't go say things
elsewhere so now you're getting paid mid
six figures some of these people get
millions of dollars you go on the TV you
say the war is wrong they stop booking
you you under contract you can't go
anywhere else you are effectively
careerless in limbo but well paid and
there's nothing you can do about it how
many of those contracts you think have
have rolled out over the last couple
years for just all of the information
covid stuff and everything because you
know when you see the memos like it
seems like everybody gets the same memos
and then everything everybody sort of
says the same thing online and then
there's a pattern to it you know well
that I think you know what we're
learning with the DHS colluding with
social media you know they're colluding
with with traditional media there's no
way that they have takedown requests of
Twitter and Facebook and they don't have
you know contacts at Major media Outlets
to talk with the heads about what
stories are good or bad put it this way
you think that if they're doing that
social media they're not going to the
New York Times being like hey that story
is really bad it's going to get people
killed they do that I guarantee you the
New York Times They probably go we'll
take it down we won't publish they
probably get a phone call like hey we
hear you're about to run a story about
this that's going to put us in Jeopardy
we're asking you not to run it they'll
go okay you got it you got it no worries
some stories they probably say will run
it anyway but they're they're that's
it's all one big club man and you ain't
in it same Club they used to beach over
the head with George Carlin the France
thing is interesting because uh they
won't they're threatening to shut down
servers from Rumble they've been funding
Ukraine you said but now they're also
taking research and development from
Russia yeah Russia is sending them new
fists I don't know if it's fissile
material but they're sending them Fusion
parts for their Fusion reactor Russia
and France are working together right
now on building a fusion reactor I don't
understand then why they would want to
shut off Russia today it's just very
strange like there's like exactly it's
like there's oligarchs and then there's
government and they're not working
together or they have different goals or
something let's talk about crazy old
Biden in this crazy old Biden story we
got for you Biden again says his son
Beau died in Iraq while catching himself
confusing the Iraq and Ukraine Wars when
discussing what caused worldwide
inflation so I don't know if they have
the uh the video here let's play yeah I
think we can play it no change in the
quality of it
just changing the price
and they talk about inflation
you know we're dealing with it for the
whole SEC inflation is a worldwide
problem right now
because of a war in Iraq and the impact
on oil and what Russia is doing I mean
excuse me the war in in Ukraine
and uh I think of Iraq because that's
where my son died
the uh because his son did not die in
Iraq he died in a hospital in the United
States correct I believe that's I
believe yeah yeah it was uh uh he had
cancer I believe but it wasn't in Iraq
this is the second time Joe Biden said
this he sounds like he's he's looking
out a window at an old Folk's home he's
like
staying on my son you know but if he was
he'd be standing there and be like yeah
it's just thinking about my son he died
in a rock and the nurse would be like
that's right right come with me and
we'll get you to bed here's your
medicine he'll be like oh I like my
medicine right there he's not wrong that
the inflation is caused by the war in
Iraq though
that's right he accidentally says yeah
he accidentally says something that's
partly true
I think the dude probably is is
he's Beyond medication you know look I
went to uh I was in Gettysburg and one
of the souvenir shops they sold pill
containers really fancy ones like the
little metal heart-shaped and you'd open
it and it was like you put your pills in
it and I'm like wow you know that's for
older people who have to take certain
medications I think Joe Biden's beyond
that like oh yeah you know he's on meds
they gotta have him on uppers and he's
still this bad I've seen videos of THC
consuming amyloid plaque which is the
plaque that grows on the blood vessels
in the brain causes Alzheimer's so
there's evidence that THC consumes that
so you're saying that Joe Biden's got a
rock to ganj if you want to get that new
bra and psilocybin I've heard is also
responsible for neurogenesis the
regrowth of brain cells so there are
alternative treatments that someone
suffering from any kind of cognitive
decline could look at Naturally stuff
like wouldn't they like these powerful
Elites know these things and be taking
these drugs or whatever I would hope so
you think so I mean like we hear all
these crazy stories about the blood of
children or whatever like we we know
there have been stories about how they
use foreskin cream on their faces and
how they do blood transfusions with
young people some billionaires even hire
young people to work out in the gym
blood boys that what they're called yeah
I mean I was joking like Silicon Valley
I think yeah oh yeah it's true story
it's like New York Times or whatever's
reporting is rich people will hire like
19 year old you know Jim Bros to do
bi-weekly blood transfusions because it
rejuvenates you if that's true come on
Biden's got to be on some crazy ass
experimental treatments to like fix his
brain he's probably doing that plus a
lot more but it's probably still not
helping because of how old he is I mean
didn't he have correct me if I'm wrong
three brain aneurysms I think it was two
um I I don't know but but that's a
serious deal and this was this was
decades and decades ago yeah uh just a
couple days ago he said that there were
54 states seven days ago he called
Kamala Harris the president of the
United States for the fifth time
um so
again this is not going to the street
your body can only do so much so even if
they're juicing them up like at some
point you know they're gonna have to cut
back I mean there is a video the other
like a month or two ago where uh two
videos in the same day and one is he's
very calm very you know is the video
that then the second video the same day
uh is the one where he wasn't blinking
and he's like staring at the camera and
he's sort of yelling and it seems like
two different guys right it's like they
maxed them out on the meds and now
they've sort of pulled back because if
they keep going with it every single day
where they have to keep him Juiced up to
get out there he's the president he's
got appointments he's got to be on TV uh
they're gonna run him dry he's gonna
drop right then and there which he also
said the other day too by the way I
could drop dead at any minute there's
that pets yeah he said that there's only
so much Adderall and adrenochrome a man
could take I mean for goodness sakes and
I'm just being facetious this year
obviously
but uh
come on come on like
I I have to believe that there is
ridiculously expensive experimental
treatments that have shown to like
de-age that they have to have access to
the metal brain stance in his in his
head I said earlier that the the THC was
dissolving the amyloid plaque in the
blood in the blood vessels actually in
the neurons in the brain that they found
that so yeah I just want to clarify that
it's not the blood vessels it's the
neurons where the plaque grows that
causes Alzheimer's that we know of do
you guys think so it was uh man it's
probably 11 years ago I went to a speech
by Aubry de gray of the sentences
foundation and he was saying that this
is 12 years ago he's like someone who's
younger than 45 today will live to be a
thousand
and he said it's not because we're going
to invent a pill that makes you live to
a thousand it's that as you're getting
older medical technology is advancing
faster than your aging so you're 50 they
invent a cure for macular degeneration
you never experience you know vision
loss then you're 60 you're having heart
troubles but then they've developed a
treatment for that heart ailment so now
your heart's fine now you're 80. he and
he was basically saying they're going to
keep finding ways basically you're aging
but science is advancing so fast they're
curing everything and then eventually
you live to be a thousand Rogan's a cool
example if you watch a show a lot you
see them get younger over the years like
what really yeah like probably like five
years ago he was looking pretty rugged
or like four years ago it was probably
just a rough week a couple weeks eating
a lot of maybe some junk or something
and then sometimes you'll see it and he
looks like five years younger I mean he
is on it he's on like the life extension
protocol yeah he said he's feeling
better because of the carnivore diet
that he tried where he was only doing
meat and he's like he's not is he still
only doing I don't think so I think he's
doing
um something November where he cuts out
all alcohol and cigarettes
over October excuse me oh yeah yeah
there's another November thing that's
not family friendly to mention here
right I do uh in in um I I do sober
forever
I just don't drink uh I had a sip of
cognac I'm not like you know I'm not
like was it called Tito or whatever like
I'll have a drink I guess if it's if the
the the situation warrants it but I
don't ever get drunk I'm assuming no
drugs no smoking nothing and uh I try to
eat I've been eating really good over
the past year like the worst thing I've
done is had like traditional desserts
maybe like 12 times in the year but for
the most part it's been like fresher and
fresher Foods eating like a steak or
fish or chicken breast with vegetables
so uh I mean that seems to be working
out I think Joe uh it maybe it's the NAD
because I remember he had that guy on
his show who talked about NAD nma and
Resveratrol you remember it must have
been David Sinclair he's out of Harvard
Harvard scientist I think it's that guy
and he's 15 but he looks 30. yes that's
Sinclair and his dad also apparently is
very young and his dog I think they were
experimenting on the dogs too and their
dogs are getting life extension really
what are they doing to the doctor NAD I
believe it's NAD you should talk to
David Sinclair he's the guy I'm gonna
look him up right now yeah yeah I have a
dog that you know would be awesome might
have been nmn nicotine mononucleotide
what if it what if it is NAD what if
what if the NAD turns out to be some
kind of like you know life extension
serum or something that's it
nicotine it's derived it's a
nicotinamide I don't know if that has
what kind of relationship that is to
nicotine itself I think it's B vitamins
I think people aren't getting enough
vitamins yeah I I don't think any one of
these therapies makes you younger or
Immortal it just makes you as you would
be if you were maxed out you know what I
mean like most people are probably
dehydrated not getting enough protein
eating too much sugar and not getting
any vitamins
especially with like most modern Foods
having no real nutritional density so
it's like most you're gonna you're gonna
go to McDonald's you're gonna get a
burger it's got 40 some odd percent of
your salt intake
it's the bread if you can even call it
that so it's like a really starchy low
protein fatty garbage with like not even
good fat
you eat these fast food burgers and it's
like weird petrofats or whatever trans
fats it's not real food yeah all cooked
that's messing everybody up yeah I will
say this have you guys have you guys
noticed that 30 year olds today look
younger than 30 year olds 10 or 20 years
ago
people have pointed this out with like
movies you'll be watching a movie and
you'll be like that dude's 30. you look
at 30 year old stay they're like little
kids how old's Tom Holland because he
looks like he's 20. yeah because he's
how old is he he's only 20. yeah that's
Hollywood maybe okay yeah he's really
young he's looking good for his age yeah
I think when it comes to like the NAD
stuff it's probably just that
there may be a correlation between
people who are interested in doing NAD
or nmn they're also taking vitamins
they're probably also eating healthy
food like you you don't get to the point
where you're doing like some crazy life
extension treatment without having first
been like I'm gonna eat salad and steaks
and chicken breasts I've also found that
the healthier I eat and the more I fast
and things like that when I do introduce
an unhealthy food it hits me harder I
can oh totally dude
this is a really Progressive idea guys
but eating right diet and exercise rest
getting good rest you sound like one of
those bigoted crazy conspiracy theorists
there it's a little bit of hate speech
but I thought I'd just throw it out
there just a little bit they want you
fat they want you fat and sickly and sad
well see you look at the pace that we're
going in our life and everything's sped
up so we're eating more fast food and
then that catches up to us later on and
then we're on meds trying to even out
what we ate our whole life McDonald's
and fast food whatever it is that we
would grow eating and then we spend the
rest of our life trying to balance that
out whereas if we ate right from the
beginning if we all taught each other to
eat right
um you know we might not be so sickly
when we're older it's a novel concept I
wonder if I think you brought this up
before Ian the reason that people looked
older was all of the uh what was it the
the lead in the air from gas oh wow did
you mention that or no I was talking
about that you talk about that yeah the
development of lead that was pretty much
all throughout the country that lowered
our IQ and uh development of small
children as well and it was in the air
because the cars driving around so
everyone's breathing in this lead
yeah aging you and making you stupid and
then uh what was there was something you
mentioned Ian I can't remember exactly
what it was
I don't know you mentioned breakfast in
the air I can't remember you mentioned
something else that I was like oh yeah
maybe that's because aging people I
remember when I was just breathing in
the garbage for instance I was like born
in 79 and when I was like in 1990 when I
was 11 or something I would look at a 40
year old and they looked like gray hair
Haggard old 40 was an old person I'm 43
now I look in the mirror and I'm like I
look like I'm [ __ ] 26. it's pardon my
that's mine
I look I look young I don't look like an
old person like not to myself when I
look in the mirror uh I don't I mean but
obviously I cut sugar way back when I
was 28 years old I got I ate this a bag
of Kit Kats and a bag of Easter egg
chocolate things two bags in one night
and I broke out into this open sore like
over where my pancreas or something I
was like this is sugar did this to me
like my skin broke open I was like I
will die if I do this so I have to stop
and it's like one of the things you just
you just cannot get fat I could not do
it I'll tell you this I cut out most
sugar and bread a year ago it's now just
about a year here so we we got covered
everybody's sick it was like over
Halloween last year we got the Joe Rogan
treatment you know the all the fancy
drugs monoclonal antibodies all that
stuff the kitchen sink they called it
and then after that
I remember I was like I'm hanging out
downstairs and I was eating salami and
cheese and then I was like you know I
realized I didn't eat any sugar today
I'm just not gonna like why start now
and so for the next few months I need
any sugar and I dropped 20 pounds like
like that and then since then I've
rarely eaten sugars or breads but this
past week we went out to eat I had a
bunch of bread my whole week was ruined
like the the last weekend not this past
weekend my whole week was ruined I was
skating I was falling I got bruised all
over I was like why am I falling like
what's I'm not eating that garbage
anymore dude I had some Taco Bell we had
a big Taco Bell Fiesta someone just
bought a bunch of Taco Bell and brought
it here who was that animal yeah 300 at
Taco Bell for the whole office so I ate
them like why I was like corn tortillas
only because I don't want to do the
wheat flour it's all wheat flour a wise
decision that's right it's a couple
coins I felt okay I ate a couple without
the shell I took away the flour just
scooped out the gooey innards and uh I
ate a couple like a day later the the
flour tortilla and and my throat was so
sore when I was I love that you thought
that there was a healthy way to improve
Taco Bell 300 to tuck them I actually I
didn't feel bad yeah the chicken was
okay yeah I think they've improved some
of their ingredients for the last 20
years I don't you don't think so I think
I think they downgraded ingredients
significantly just like everywhere else
you look at the food quality it's going
down you look at the nutritional value
it's going down you look at the value of
of just how much you would get from an
average tomato or apple a few years ago
compared to what we have now the GMO
Frankenstein glycophate filled plastic
nonsense bull crap that some people are
saying is food it's not food it's it's
chemically engineered chemicals that
make your brain feel good but utterly
destroy your body and cause inflammation
in a way where your body doesn't know
what to deal with it as as we are seeing
rises in obesity rises in cancer Rises
and sicknesses and illnesses that are
going up and up and up why is that
happening well our food is being
deliberately destroyed and centralized
by powerful forces like Bill Gates
Monsanto and other evil people that also
believe that there's too many people in
this world faux food or food
yeah
I'm not looking forward to Bill Gates
food Cube and the poop water you're not
you don't want the poop water yeah you
ever see that photo where it's like
there's a disaster like a hurricane was
coming and then all of the shelves are
stripped bare except for the vegan
section
nobody nobody was like I mean or the
animals when they're presented with real
food and vegan food they're like we're
gonna want that vegan crap we don't want
that GMO genetically modified
Frankenstein made up food in a
laboratory come on and and a lot of the
studies talking about the nutritional
value of them all manipulated all fixed
a lot of the scientists were paid off
just to make it look bad because there's
a big business investment into this you
gotta eat the bugs which is also
horrible for you and gives people
parasites and lectins and all their
horrible things that people have to deal
with that is not good for you you know
what you know what's good for you actual
food you know what we don't have actual
food it's crazy is the Monsanto stuff
really has me concerned because they
weren't in the 90s I don't remember
Monsanto being that big of a deal it was
like 2005 or this when I start to
realize that this Mega Corporation has
been spraying huge swaths of land with
this chemical glyphosate that you
brought up as they have a revolving door
within the FDA and the regulatory
government boards that of course watches
over them and decides major decisions
for them they they started working with
other biotech Industries I don't know
who exactly is doing it all but they
genetically modify seeds to be resistant
to a pesticide or I think it's an
herbicide that they create called
glyphosate so they G they genetically
modify seeds that can resist this
herbicide and then so the farmers have
to buy the the Monsanto seed in order to
resist the Monsanto herbicide otherwise
otherwise they're on their own in a lot
of ways and so for profit they'll do
that but then once you start spraying
your land with glyphosate there's no
turning back you can't use normal seeds
because they'll die off from the
glyphosate you have to keep buying these
genetically modified seeds and it
destroys not only the bad bacteria but
the good bacteria as well so essentially
when you're taking something that's like
glycipate a lot of scientists have
described it as taking antibiotics
because it destroys also your gut biome
and with the destruction of your gut
biome you get a lot of horrible symptoms
that are are shown and highlighted and
are increasing in our society you not
only get irritable bowel syndrome but
you also get mental problems you also
get physical health problems you also
get the destruction of your immune
system a lot of this is correlated with
just your gut the engine of your human
body that's being utterly eviscerated
not just by medical doctors giving out
uh you know antibiotics like like
they're candy but also because of the
food which contains glycemate it's
gotten to the point where when they go
to harvest wheat if it's if they want to
speed up the Harvest they needed to get
ready to harvest faster so they need to
dry it out because it's still wet so
they'll use glyphosate as a desiccant to
dry out the wheat right before they
harvest it so I mean if you don't have
organic wheat I swear that I notice a
difference in The Taste between organic
wheat and naan or any any other NBC News
has an article that I think might be
worth pulling up it's titled a potential
cancer causing chemical is sprayed on
much of America's Farmland here is where
it used it is used the most and of
course we're talking about the weed
killer glycephate by Monsanto that now
is controlled by Bayer the company that
also a couple years ago knowingly gave
out you know just this just medication
linked with AIDS is Roundup glyphosate
yes yes it is yes popular weed killers
alleged linked to cancer stir's
widespread concern yeah and there's many
lawsuits that have been successfully
launched against Santo because they are
showing the emails the data the fudged
uh you know scientific data The fudged
Regulators that were bought off by them
that of course knowingly knew that they
hey there's a link here to cancer we're
just going to use it anyway and we're
going to suppress this story look at
this clumps of dandelions have popped up
in your yard so you reach for a bottle
of Roundup the popular weed killer it's
known for being effective but its main
ingredient glyphosate is getting a lot
of attention because of lawsuits alleges
alleging links to cancer I just want to
say this
dandelions weeds you eat them you make
dandelion tea and you eat them it's uh
uh so they were brought here I think you
told me this they were brought here from
Europe or someone did and uh for their
medicinal purposes and we see them all
over the place but they're actually not
not native to North America they were
like prized back in the day and I guess
in Appalachia it's a common thing to
take the heads and batter and deep fry
them and they apparently taste like
mushrooms it's like really good so uh
they're not weeds if if here's what you
do if any you harvest them and if you're
concerned about what anyone might say
when you try to offer them deep fried
dandelions just call them dandelions
they won't know what you're talking
about and then they'll eat it and then
you can tell them it's a dandelion from
your garden or stop being a lazy bum and
actually start working in the fields and
get your hands dirty in the dirt with
good bacteria and actually rip out the
weeds and actually do some real farming
instead of being dependent on a
multinational corporation that of course
is connected to Bill Gates one of their
biggest investors that has been spraying
known uh according to many lawsuits and
court cases a cancer-causing chemicals
on on a lot of the products and a lot of
the environment all around us and it's
also important to note here corn and soy
are some of the biggest products that
are affected by glycipate are the
products that are most sprayed with it
and when you look at corn and soy I
think it's fair to say that this
subsidized crop in the United States has
been leading to a lot of Havoc not only
with monocraft been getting rid of the
nutrients from the soil but but
specifically on a nutritional level
because it's GMO because it has so much
glycopate in it we are seeing it
everywhere in our food all the sugars
are synthetic all the sugars have high
fructose corn syrup your mayonnaise has
high fructose no mine doesn't
well the ones that you were you're taken
down we were right taken down the red
sheets and the packets of Heinz
mayonnaise had corn syrup in it yeah
yeah but uh the helmet stuff I have has
no cornstarch
lifo Sate I'll say it like I want to say
no it's glyphosate it doesn't have any
respect for me and and you know I don't
care they've remarketed uh high fructose
corn syrup as fructose glucose fructose
yeah so if you see that on your later
that's high fructose corns you know my
childhood wasn't it 80s 90s my favorite
my favorite 92 is when it got popular my
favorite my favorite rebranding is table
syrup oh I know so Sports herb yeah it's
just it's corn syrup marketed as like a
breakfast pancake syrup or whatever yeah
yeah just think about how disgusting
this is okay look there's a reason why
we would put maple syrup on our food
it's like maple syrup is real food so
you know you get out of a tree it's
sugar it's it's it's a it's a you know
product you can do things with it you
can make they make like little little
Maple discs you put in your car they're
fantastic and so then people like to put
maple syrup on their breakfast so then
somebody was like Hey look this corn
syrup is cheaper to produce so they
started making you know corn syrup
additives and calling it maple syrup
eventually the government's like hey you
can't call it that
basically you have this disgusting
chemical mix on your table to pour onto
your already starch breakfast I just
find it absolutely disgusting that's
wild table syrup I love how they
rebranded it yeah tables I used to do it
of maple syrup I'd be like all right
let's do this I need a sugar Spike and I
do I do like a shot of maple syrup and
it would be like like God entered my
body and gave me wisdom and joy and all
this and I'm like wow immediately I
wanted another one my body's like yes do
that again so I I would experiment and I
would reach for and I'd do a second shot
and it would taste like I was drinking
black nasty death like it was just like
poison it was just too much sugar like
you don't need the body immediately when
it feels good it wants it again it
doesn't mean that you're going to feel
the same way the second time you do it
so I realize when you want that
addictive second shot just put it down
well high fructose corn syrup has been
engineered in a way so your body doesn't
reject it like it does natural sugar so
if you're eating natural sugar your body
says hey you're getting too much sugar
stop eating all these berries up eating
all these fruits but but high fructose
corn syrup has been engineered in a way
where that shut off valve can't exist in
your human body and it doesn't work with
it so you're able to consume huge sums
of high fructose corn syrup and
corporations even have a level where
it's the exact amount where your body is
able to take as much of it as as it can
without actually puking and a lot of
Corporations fill it to the Max and try
to go to that extreme level you know the
association Point Association point
exactly for breakfast I've been having
two eggs fresh from chicken City and
three bacon we've been doing just
regular old store-bought bacon but
sometimes if we make it out to the farm
we'll get Farm bacon and you don't need
to add anything to it now Bacon's
already very salty or whatever but you
don't need sugar it's just fat and
protein and it's just it's it's perfect
I like putting a little black pepper on
it's about it
people people who have these crazy
sugary massive breakfast with pancakes
and orange juice and whatever I can't
understand that's so brutal it's kind of
weird how like we've been brainwashed to
think that you need foods with foods
like certain foods like you can't have a
hummus without a scooping cracker like
I'd just ignore the crackers you don't
eat crackers just eat the hummus was it
orange uh juice Edward Bernays and so is
bacon yep they were both the uh at least
okay this is what I read you know this
is what I was told bacon was not a
breakfast food but they were like let's
Market it as like the All-American
breakfast food and orange juice was
because there was an orange Surplus so
the farmers and Distributors were like
how do we sell off without losing money
and he was like
take a portion of the oranges out of the
market juice them and then we'll tell
everybody if one glass of orange juice
has five oranges it's five times as
healthy how about that in reality that
sugar is there's more sugar and orange
juice than like a can of Coke or
something like that so it's and it's
pure fructose just to go to your liver
and it's very very heavy you eat an
orange you're in good shape you know
it's got some sugar but you get a lot of
that dietary fiber and vitamins orange
juices hyper concentrated with no fiber
also when you eat the orange uh eat off
a little bit of that white pith from
inside the it's really good with the
juicy orange part
I had a chocolate covered orange peel
yeah basically we had a bunch everybody
ate it they ate it super fast that was
crazy candied orange peels yeah we I
bought some thinking like this is going
to be gross and no one's going to want
to eat it it was the first thing to go
people love eating orange peel a lot of
fruits like that can't you eat the
banana peel too you think so I think so
I wouldn't want to how what do you do
prepare a banana peel I don't know you
can you can uh well I need to caramelize
them and stuff really yeah oh I think
I've seen it it's all plant matter I
mean you know yeah I think our
generation's so conscious of all this
stuff because I was having this
conversation last night about 80s and
90s kids growing up and you think about
the food that we had growing up every
breakfast was a dessert you know we had
Fruity Pebbles and cartoon characters
cookie crisps and stuff and then every
meal was based around pizza for the most
part you had Totino's party pizzas and
Bagel Bites that was my idea growing up
you know and uh and hamburgers so like
we're we're sort of starting to feel the
repercussions of this so I think that
now we're we're kind of a lot more
conscious of it nowadays we were going
by the food pyramid which was yeah so
right it's actually an economic model
like it was made for the same thing
where they want they had so much wheat
production they want to they want to
increase action in the U.S so that we
would just make okay make everyone eat
it all the time every day also before we
go into Super chats I'm getting
information that Viva Frey did not
comply with oh really take down orders
and that his account was just reinstated
without him having to click that he was
wrong oh on Twitter so that's just what
people are sending me and and Viva Frey
is saying it on Twitter just for a
direction for him the earlier correction
apologies Viva
um glad to hear that you stood your
ground and ultimately it worked out
apparently you could make bacon out of
banana peels what dude I'm telling you
holy oh really yeah that's interesting
you ever make a watermelon steak no this
is actually really cool you you take a
big slice of watermelon you put it
between paper towels put in the fridge
and leave it overnight which dries it
out a bit then you can marinate it
season it and bake it and it ends up
having the consistency of like a piece
of tuna and so we would we would we
would cook it with like garlic and onion
and maybe like a little soy sauce for
flavor and then we would make sandwiches
with it and it's delicious because it's
it's it's not there's not a lot of
flavor in it after you you dry it out so
you're basically just getting like a
firm dietary fiber Mash with whatever
flavor you put in it cool stuff we're
gonna go to super chats if you haven't
already would you kindly smash that like
button subscribe to this Channel and
share this show with your friends tell
them all it's the best show ever at
least that's what I was told head over
to timcast.com and become a member we
have a members only show coming up for
you at about 11 pm you don't want to
miss it uncensored not so family
friendly let's read some super chats
pirate Taurus second half says I suspect
Raymond g Stanley Jr is a bot prove me
wrong by inviting him and other super
fans to the show
I like that idea it is a good idea we
will have to organize it maybe after the
holidays because we've got a bunch of
stuff coming up that's really crazy
oh man the coordination for these
projects we're doing it's just it's it's
intense we're going to be in Phoenix I'm
going to be at uh Turning Point USA
we're going to be doing the show I don't
know if I'm supposed to say this now or
whatever I'm going to be doing the show
on the stage with uh TP USA so I'm
really excited for that but it just it's
just like a logistical heavy lift so
it's going to be very very rough but
we'll figure it out you know we'll get
it going it's gonna be really really
cool I'm really excited for it so shout
out Jack besobic
all right Jay Marie says Dia de los
Muertos Day of the Dead is tonight it's
a beautiful part of our Latin culture I
made a film for our celebration here in
Dallas I know everyone will love j marie
thesis podcast oh very cool I dig it
all right
let's grab some super chats
Rose blight says if you haven't already
get survival food and TP it's gonna get
weirder very quickly yes and you all
know our good friends over a safe and
over at safe and readymeals.com
um I I only shout them out when it's
really bad
so they're a sponsor of the show
periodically safe and readymeals.com
it's emergency food if you're interested
I I think you know you get one of these
buckets after 25 years you put in your
closet you forget about it if you're
really worried you get a ton of them or
whatever it is you want to do the crazy
thing is when I first started shouting
them out they were cheaper than they are
now but inflation hit but they last 25
years so if you bought it two years ago
you would have saved money because it
lasted 25 years now if you buy it sure
you get two years but now it's like more
expensive so
all right
what do we have here
sleep is the cousin of death says Elon
is smart the big ask twenty dollars but
makes it eight art that's right that's
right
Captain tanker Joe says Tim I'm a truck
driver and I just filled up my truck
right before the stream went live just
over seven hundred dollars I do this
every two to three days and the company
I work for is a fleet of 1500 doing the
same thing
you will owe nothing and you will be
happy that was my Biden impersonation
everybody I hope you were creeped out
you're supposed to yell half of it
you'll owe nothing and you will be no
all right all right let's grab some more
Super Giants
stinky whiz whistle teats says don't
worry the shortages will be transitory
and then when they're not transitory
they'll say the Shorties are actually a
good thing
remember during lockdown they said the
Earth is healing I think it was a New
York Times article the Earth is healing
we force you into your homes it's a good
thing
vote for it how about that
let's see no comprendo the beanie Puffs
are used to keep Sailors from hitting
their heads inside the holes and doors
in cramped locations yeah is that real I
think it I think it is it wouldn't it be
for like when you're just doing the hat
and you have to cover the little top
seam as well I don't know who knows I
guess it makes sense if you're on a boat
and you bounce your head but that's not
I can't imagine it's actually going to
do much to help you I feel like these
hats came out before steel ships didn't
they yeah oh yeah yeah Fez The Fez is
ancient I don't know how old that is Mr
trench trucker says as a trucker I am
prepping for a Mad Max scenario I broke
down today and lost about a hundred
dollars in diesel for a load I couldn't
pick up
uh food needs diesel that's right
it's going to be crazy man
David fitzsimmon says Ian in regards to
your musings of game elements and social
media a hentai site beat you 10 years
ago had random text prompts of a little
event or a monster that can be fought
for points for downloads
well okay I mean like porn makes uh was
there like some story how like the
internet greatly improved because of
demand for porn like the internet speeds
were being increased because people
wanted to watch like adult content or
something I've heard that before well
there you go
what do you really need six six gigabits
for trust me
Jeremy grow says have we forgotten the
warning from the freight industry that
Regulators were reducing the number of
diesel tankers allowed per train El
Grande rienciar
is that how you say it
yeah it looks right to me no I mean is
that the word
El Grande yes
I mean great Renaissance yeah I think so
come on the great almost there the great
ravaging what are we talking about uh
reintroduction of policy the the
resuscitate
we'll figure it out
it's gonna be great whatever
lunger 77 says Fox 10 in Arizona
accidentally posted Kerry Lake's defeat
during a live news broadcast they said
it was just a test I saw that I mean
honestly guys it usually is they'll
create fake graphics and then someone
will press the wrong button you know I
don't know what I'll say what else what
else to tell you we'll see
why wouldn't they just put 50 50 though
for a test sure but if you're really
worried about it and you think something
dastardly is afoot you better get your
friends out to go vote you better get
all your friends in bed let's go vote
go knock on doors
Michael Bauer I'm a long time listener
but it's my first time writing a super
chat I met Brad nine years ago at EKU I
was a student worker that helped Brad
with his concert thanks everyone for all
you do oh very cool I remember that do
you have any shows lined up
um there's a lot of talk about
um a lot of different rallies and
freedom concerts
um that are we're trying to do some um
kind of uh Coachella kind of events next
year bigger events
um I'm not really interested in doing
like a tour the traditional tour I'd
like to just you know do bigger events
and get some other artists together to
do that kind of stuff we just went over
to uh what was the name of that Festival
where we met up with Adelitas Blue Ridge
Blue Ridge Rockville it was fantastic
yeah that was super cool I imagine it
was a bunch of like-minded people or
like people they're just fed up with the
coveted lockdowns basically and they're
like that's what we want to do yeah
outdoor it was sauce Tenacious D was
amazing
yeah front of the crowd yes whatever
super awesome do stuff like that yeah
I'll do fake blood show sure oh okay
Pina Shay's helicopter tour says another
thing to consider when there's no diesel
there's no food when there's no food
Riot when people Riot the National Guard
gets called when there's no diesel
National Guard goes nowhere this could
be fun I mean we've been saying get out
of the Cities if you haven't maybe it'll
be all right I don't know maybe it's all
just hype and blather and nothing will
happen and you can watch your football
games or whatever I hope so even if
nothing happens though like a lot of
this stuff just being prepared anyway is
smart I was at a prepper Camp a few
weeks ago actually and it was pretty
cool and but it puts you in the right
mindset of like getting your you know
stock food together and getting enough
water together and
stocking up on gasoline if you if you
need it and getting a generator all that
stuff everybody should sort of just know
that stuff but we're so you know
uh not in with it every from the day to
day
yeah Andrew G says Tim I run one of the
largest gun store shooting ranges in
central Ohio ATF just rolled out a new
crazy background check system nobody's
talking about would love to come out and
talk gun regulations and ATF with you
guys we we need to set up a new email
um for people to send information to I
don't know we got to figure it out we'll
get there man we'll take a look into
that though
New Zealand does not exist says thank
you for mentioning Aiden Paladin last
week she's one of my favorite uh
favorites on YouTube very intelligent
and a dank memer as well she's perfect
for the timcast audience and will make a
good guest that is a good point
you're correct
all right moving on she uh she had this
post about scientific studies showing
how the left is just uh
what's the right word suaved in greed
Envy hate and violence
there's a bunch of scientific studies
like outlining it I think it makes sense
because it's not so much that the left
there's the left and the right have
changed it used to be the right stood
for something the left said for
something the words meant mean things
now they're just tribal signifiers and
so if you are more envious hateful and
ignorant you end up in the left space if
you are inquisitive
and I guess
um you know more more apt to compromise
and and opposing of violence you're
going to end up more in the right side
and that's why traditional liberals
disaffected liberals post-liberals
Libertarians are all called to fall
right because the left says if you're if
you're not with us you're against us and
a Libertarian and a conservative who
completely disagree on really core
issues will hang out and laugh together
yeah like it was just one of the best
episodes we've ever had was with Austin
Peterson Will Chamberlain Sheamus me and
uh Ian we're we're all completely in
disagreement with tons of things will
Chamberlain's like I actually the
Federal Reserve is good and everyone's
like ah they're all yelling and we all
disagree but we all have a great time
arguing and having these ideas
how is that just the right like just so
many different ideas there from from
more authoritarian ideas to more
left-leading ideas
is meaningless so they needed studies
for that yeah well the studies they do
because they show like bullying is
intrinsic among uh as a correlation
between bullying and having leftist
values that was one of the studies I was
looking at that's interesting because in
the mainstream media it seems to be uh
the message is the opposite of that yeah
but they're bullying right
okay
Nathaniel Lipscomb says they travel with
Nancy the security I mean that's a fair
point but um why wouldn't their house
have security I just I don't I don't get
it
the house would have security they have
stupid money they at least have cameras
outside at the bare minimum yeah we've
got a camera gotta spend that money
somewhere right right Tom Forsyth says
de Pape it's me Dave I got the stuff
Pelosi Dave's not here
Dave's not here man
foreign
says enforcement arm for collectivist
Democrats military wing of the DNC wear
uniforms to hide identity calling
calling cards is burning and
intimidation is that the clan or antifa
is there a difference aha
got him
got him yeah that's right
Ryan Miller says a little late to the
party so forgive if this is already been
answered but the puff ball was used by
Sailors for a for a time to make sure
they had head clearance
okay that corroborates the earlier but I
don't understand that makes sense if you
don't have head clearance you Bang Your
Head yeah what does that mean I don't
know about that someone just Google it
they're probably right I guess
it has clearance but not as a protective
measure like it wasn't the other the
earlier one was again if you bumped your
head or something it was like uh if you
bumped your head on like I guess like
imagine a steel deck or a wood beam
you'd have some kind of protection but
it's not gonna help oh that really hurt
but I'm so thankful that little puffball
was up on top yeah
let's see uh blue de Golia I live five
I've lived five blocks from the Pelosi
house and my early morning walks went
right past their place on three
occasions I was stopped by cops and
unmarked cars for watching the sunrise
from the sidewalk
interesting hmm
John Leroy says Tim your story doesn't
explain the extra guy involved with
Paul's crashed Porsches that was left
out of the police report
also very interesting
I have no idea man love her powerful
people can make whatever they want to
happen
yep Yahtzee says Trump wins in 2024
Democrat held States refuse to certify
the election the Republican held House
and Senate certify anyway Civil War
ensues thoughts yeah agreed moving on no
what do you guys think
I don't think Trump is going to win
um I wouldn't be against something like
that happening but I just feel like
there's so much animosity and and you
know obviously the DHS Department of
Homeland Security is working with what
social media to suppress things they
were they're explicit about that I so
that signs point me to that direction
and don't be upset if that direction
happens you know kind of thing there's
still going to be a country in a few
years from now yeah let's start there I
like I like this super chat right here
this is a fun fun story Nathan C says
Pelosi probably is a serial killer his
victim fought back called the cops they
came and arrested the victim and covered
it up for Pelosi who's Above the Law if
not how would it look any different hey
I'm sure but I mean like if you want to
believe that you could all say Paul
Pelosi is an alien who is trying to
abduct uh Papi and the security guards
and the governor run by aliens so how
would it look any different well there
you go it's you know I believe what you
want to believe both could be true
yeah his his uh his real name is beat
Bart
why do how come how come alien names
always are like with x's and Z's you
know like why can't an alien just be a
like
Bob yeah Bill Greg Greg Greg absorb it's
always it's always like yeah zorbon Zeba
Thor why can't it be like
foam yeah you know or like like blam
give us some you know S's and R's in
there and some neutral sounding letters
Zeno has to do has to do with foreigners
x-e-n-o that's why I guess right
x e and l okay all right mimic says
Stephen King shouldn't pay for
verification that way when they take
away the badge I can create a Stephen
King count pay for the badge and be
verified then praise Trump all day as
Stephen King
but that's the thing these people are
lying about clearly they're like why
would I want to be on a platform where
bloogie2937 is verified with a picture
of a dog and then people are going to
imitate me and get verified it's like
are you dumb do you really think they're
gonna no they're lying verification is
if you are who you say you are and you
take a picture of your ID and your
credit card or whatever they give you a
badge that's it they literally verify
you are who you say you are they're not
gonna let people imitate you and
verified accounts are probably only
going to be people who have like actual
bios or something
and Brands I guess
Terry Boyd says he may have asked
where's Nancy to make sure she wasn't
home so they could party on
see that's how they're doing it
I'm not your buddy guy says Viva didn't
comply he refused to bear false witness
to himself citing James O'Keefe biggest
regret oh okay all right I was wrong
about that apologies Viva I know we said
that already but I'll say it again my
mistake I thought because he posted a
picture I thought he clicked the you
know delete tweet button yeah
okay
what is this Tom Brady says Luke what
water filter filters everything
that's a great question
um
I forgot the exact name of it but
there's a particular one that you could
install in your house a lot of them are
pretty pricey and expensive uh but also
if you filter out water you have to add
minerals to it because then your body
will of course be lacking those minerals
as well so do your homework especially
when it comes to water filtration
because you could also be hurting your
body not even knowing it thinking you're
just filtering your water and uh when
they come and install your water they
say they want to add minerals ask them
what kind and if they can't tell you
then you should probably be like well
I'm not putting weird stuff in my water
because I've heard stories of them being
like Oh it's like basic stuff fluoride
you know isn't that crazy we haven't
figured out water yet yeah like the most
important thing for our body and we're
still like okay I've heard that silver
makes a good water filter and also
graphene we're still in the beginning of
graphene water filtration whatever Nano
gold out of water and stuff with what
whatever Bill Gates used to clean the
poop and then drink it Bill Gates drank
poo water like he does a big thing about
it yeah yeah he's on camera doing it
right when it comes out and then he's
like poop yeah exactly they probably
came to him and they're like do you want
those videos and photos released from
that Island are you gonna drink the poop
water what's the toys here Bill he's
like crying about it while he's doing it
sustaining stewardship says Tim it would
be gorsum if you had Marty bent on to
discuss energy and Bitcoin really cool
dude would make a great show Hey listen
English is my second language you son of
a gun
too I'm a person of color watch watch
where you step number three gorsum is a
word that other people have used in
their vernaculars and I'm not the first
person to use it it actually has its own
Wikipedia entry does it or some yes and
people have a meaning towards it uh you
know yeah towards it obviously and a
definition of it meaning uh you know
what is it um fact check the gross and
gorsum act is certainly capable of
turning the staunchest butcher's stomach
fact check punk I was right that's from
that's where I'm sitting right now
Timothy I was right you don't really go
with it it's language is Magic five 5G
chess IQ genius here clearly
Tom Penny says my favorite lucasm is
when he says brand spanking new blank
but switches the word spanking and new
is that a Lucas that's that's the
English language
a brand new spanking thing I like that
yeah my brain works in different way I
dream in like polish which which is
which is so weird but but again I I
communicate with my family as well and I
have to again just kind of switch my
brain to speak Polish and then speaking
English sometimes is uh not that easy
for me but I'm you know I'm doing my
best so I I appreciate the the teasing
are you like super fluid with Polish uh
it depends because the the less I use it
the harder it is to to even you know
talk but but it's easier for me to talk
polish than pondering pondering life
says salts and eatsin talked about
people being charged for arbitrary Evil
under article 58 always for anti-soviet
agitation
man that's that's the guy who did the
Goulet archipelago yeah that book
charged for crazy
Thomas
tjg says the third guy was de Papi's
pimp collecting what Pelosi owed the
poppy in the middle of trying to stop
the pimp with the hammer pulls it out of
his hands the cops show up into papa is
caught with a hammer I love all of these
wild stories because you can really just
make up whatever you want yeah how about
this one
um it wasn't actually either it wasn't
Paul who called the police it was an
agitated third party see the three of
them were building a birdhouse and this
third guy got angry and called the cops
and staged it and then let the cops in
the cops then see them both holding the
hammer together trying to build a
birdhouse in Tandem and then they
assumed it was violent and started
beating the crap out of him and then
said oh no that was Paul Pelosi what do
we do blame the other guy because they
were building it for Nancy for her
birthday right where's Nancy I need to
ask her something
it's hard work making a birdhouse that's
right it was a it was a it was a big one
yeah you know they got really sweaty and
you know
yeah things just naturally happened
okay
Chris Bradley says Dr Shiva ianduri
exposed the DHS to censorship network
two years ago all of this is documented
in public record in the federal lawsuit
Aya durai versus Twitter at all
120 CV 11889 document number 195.
interesting hmm
the deep fryer says Tim I need to call
you out for your earlier video ragging
on the blue check marks while
simultaneously making excuses for
yourself to not abandon the watch count
back your talk up with the walk no I I
made two different points one was I
don't know why in the age of digital
media everything's got to have a number
to show you how well something's done
as for Twitter
I would love it if they got rid of the
follow account the light count and the
retweet count and all that stuff as for
YouTube what I said was Honestly though
I don't know if that is good to turn off
because it may have an impact on how
YouTube distributes your content so I'm
not going to intentionally hobble my
channels but if YouTube were to get rid
of view count then okay so be it
big difference
okay
let's see oh Chris Bradley giving us
more more money say his name or prove
you're a fraud Dr Shiva ayadurai exposed
the dhss DHS censorship network two
years ago I love these like um ultimatum
super chats I'm giving you money you
better say it or else
okay dude thanks for the money though
it's like I read it and then later on he
gets mad that I didn't read it yet but I
didn't read it patience yeah it's like I
can't read every single one
oh what do we got here
let's see Rob gratt says Luke look at
your insta inbox sent you a sketch of a
Bill Gates in budaposed t-shirt in
budapose I'm gonna check it out thank
you so much for messaging me at Luke we
are change on there Raymond g Stanley Jr
says Ian bro is a fellow 40 we got them
bags bro
we got them bags bro what's he talking
about your eyes maybe oh underneath
money bags money bags
Michael Hinton says do you think the
media is saying the Pelosi attacker is a
queue guy so going into the elections
the leftists can say see you we told you
these people are dangerous vote for us
and we'll stop them yeah absolutely
probably I think that's why they're so
eager to push it
Pali Bruce says Pinochet did not throw
people out of helicopters Ian Allende
was a communist revolutionary that
violated the Constitution smuggle
weapons and Cuban soldiers stay in power
the suicide is contested yeah the
suicide Allende is the guy that was in
the Capitol building and then all of a
sudden right when like pinochet's men
were going to take it and create the
Revolution and uh ayende killed himself
in Quotes no one really knows if he did
or if they at gunpoint were like
here's one to the Head uh I don't know
I've heard from multiple people that
Pinochet did throw dudes out of
helicopters you know if you've got
evidence to suggest otherwise send it to
me on Twitter or mine so I can look at
it James savick says Biden has been
dumping in the Strategic petroleum
Reserve to depress gas prices while he's
poking Russia with a stick when they
stop dumping the reserve gas will Spike
and who knows what Putin will do
man bear pig says I'd like to negotiate
further with Elon Musk regarding Twitter
blue tree fitty there you go
I honestly think he could charge way
more
uh if you're a big brand in a big
company and you want access to all these
special tools and data analytics you'll
pay for it that being said it they need
to pay their top creators who make
content and they got to figure out how
to do that so I honestly don't know how
you do it I don't know he's also talking
about bringing back Vine so there's a
lot of opportunities and potential there
and if you have people paying eight
bucks a month that's a lot of money that
you could share the revenue with or even
do an affiliate sale being like hey if
you get more people to sign up you get a
commission you know yeah just make to a
Twitter pyramid scheme everybody who
signs up using your promo code you get
10 cents for you know you get a dollar
for the rest as long as they're paying
members and then anyone they sign up you
get 10 of and when they sign up you get
10 of you see they're multi-level
marketing is called right yeah yeah that
wouldn't work you can work your way
towards a blue check there you go that's
right Justin ask with says shuwon head
and Sam Hyde as guests bonus points if
you get them both on at the same episode
we we uh almost almost got Sam Hyde on
it was going to be before his big boxing
match and then we didn't I don't know
what happened I think we could I know
him well shuwon had we've invited
several times but I just don't think she
wants to come on the show so yeah Sam's
down it was just a a scheduling issue at
the time Hyde would be awesome yeah yeah
I mean that would be a great job with
shoe on it at the same time that's tough
who knows we uh we did we did book uh
Shu and Alex Jones for the same episode
but then shoe canceled would have been
good shoe yeah yeah it's too bad all
right let's make it happen it's too bad
uh and then I've invited her several
times after but she's just you know
doesn't want to do it I guess for
whatever reason I don't know man yeah I
wonder why you know what I will say
though and this is not indicative of
shoe because Shu often does talk about a
lot of these things and call out the
establishment but a lot of the uh old
school anti-sjw anti-wolf crowd totally
just panicked wet their pants and then
started deleting videos and hiding yeah
all their old videos all the past videos
yeah they just totally lost it yeah I
got scared they got scared some people
abandoned it outright stopped making
content some deleted their their most
prominent videos and just totally
panicked I can empathize with the Panic
it's it's tough to get red pilled when
people around you aren't getting red
pilled it can feel very isolating yeah I
mean I don't know if you're a coward
then that's fine just let everybody know
but I guess we do know that you're a
coward so whatever
that's fine
Mira rora says please fix the ads of the
podcast having ads injected in the
middle of a sentence makes the
discussion very difficult to follow
there's just like no real way to do
anything about that because we're all
talking Non-Stop and often talking over
each other but that's how all podcasts
do it so yeah
all right Bryce e says the guy before
was correct Pinochet didn't throw people
out of helicopters because Communists
aren't people
okay well I I do have to say this you
know we're hoping that this election can
clear up a lot of uh the air and perhaps
lead to some inquiries and maybe
de-escalate things so we don't see
violence or dehumanizing dehumanizing
language in the long run but I do think
it's important to point out that the
original 1964 Human Rights Act
specifically says that Communists aren't
people
wow it yeah wow it doesn't say they
aren't people it says that they're not
protected it says that this bill will
not be construed to protect members of
communist Affiliated organizations Etc
so that's actually really interesting
they get denied human rights I see here
there's this thing called Death flights
if you look up on Wikipedia and or
regular uh
augusto's former personal helicopter
pilot has admitted that on numerous
occasions he threw prisoners into the
ocean or into the high peaks of the
Andes well if you haven't already would
you kindly smash that like button
subscribe to this Channel and share this
show take that URL post it wherever you
can let your friends note about it know
about it it's the best way to help out
you can follow the show at timcast IRL
you can follow me personally at timcast
five times August do you want to shut
anything out
got a new album out today I heard that's
cool I'm sitting right behind you is
yeah where do people get this where can
people find you well it's out now on uh
Apple music Amazon Spotify you can check
it out and uh you can get the CD at five
times August can I say are these yeah
what's the name of this is it very
political it's very political it's very
political it's I've switched my whole
career over to being an angry
protestinger anti-fascist Blues Joe sad
little man yeah a lot of people know you
for side little man I have something
calling out fauci yeah what's the name
of the album silent War yeah and then
people could find it where five
timesaugust.com or on Apple Amazon
YouTube Spotify band camp it's out there
well thank you thank you so much for
coming and thank you thank you so much
guys for the memes yeah you know and
that's that's I'll go straight back to
work now and get back there get in there
calling out everybody on Twitter and uh
if you guys want to support a person of
color business you can by going to
youtube.com forward slash we are change
I did a video today about Brazil China
and and apparently Biden screaming at
zelinski that plus a lot more check it
out right now on youtube.com forward
slash we are change see you there I
spent my night thinking about how to
terraform Mars a lot of people were
saying it's the core Mars core uh is not
moving fast enough to produce a magnetic
field so I was like well bombing the the
poles with nuke seems like that's not
going to get to and it might create a a
core reaction but like drilling's too
expensive it seems like to get down
there so what if we just electrocute the
planet what if we create like a static
shock from the Sun cause an end point in
Martian surface or atmosphere to shock
that thing like like clear and then we
hit it with those defibrillators to uh
to get it going again let me know what
you think if that's potential if I mean
obviously there's a lot of danger
involved with sending a solar shock into
a planet but uh let me know what you
think on Twitter on mines happy to be
here and I'll catch you tomorrow those
are some big defibrillators man for a
whole planet yeah that's pretty big
anyways guys I'm at surf.com you can
find me on Twitter now I'm not uh search
actually the other guy who's trying to
beat me with you but like an IRL thing
in his profile picture on YouTube if you
don't think that's me but it's at
surge.com I'm gonna follow that guy all
right everybody we will see you all over
at timcast.com about 11 p.m for that
members show thanks for hanging out
cheers